das
Heute ist richtig gutes Wetter, aber ich bin meine eineinhalb Stunden schon gelaufen.
Ich hab jetzt den ganzen Tag nichts anderes mehr vor.
Oh, ich seh gerade, ich hab den Chat gar nicht richtig auf.
Sack.
Jetzt.
jetzt tatsächlich mal zur Abwechslung. Es gibt nämlich einen neuen Half-Life 1 Mod
und nachdem ich einmal jährlich Half-Life 1, also mindestens einmal jährlich, Half-Life
1 durchspiele, freue ich mich schon die ganze Zeit drauf mal wieder das Original zu spielen.
Allerdings mit Mod-Gear.
Wir spielen das heute mit M-Mod.
Gibt es auf Steam, kostet nix.
Äh, nicht Mod, M-Mod, Steam.
Kam es vor ein paar Wochen raus.
Und ich hab gestern schon mal so eine halbe Stunde reingeguckt,
so reingeguckt, so krumm, weil ich wissen wollte, was mich so ungefähr erwartet, ja?
Äh, weil bei Half-Life-Mods gibt's ja alles.
Ich glaub, Half-Life dürfte somit das meist gemoddete Game
aller Zeiten sein und weiß ich nicht, ob das, also
auf jeden Fall, auf jeden Fall vorne mit dabei, ja?
Dass die Musik nicht zu laut ist.
Minecraft, vielleicht, wobei, ganz ehrlich,
wahrscheinlich immer noch Half-Life, weil einfach Half-Life irgendwie 15 Jahre Vorsprung hatte vor Minecraft.
Wobei Minecraft ist auch alt, wenn man 10 Jahre Vorsprung hatte von Minecraft.
Ja zumindest, soweit ich das gelesen habe, haben die einige Sachen überarbeitet.
Also es ist die originale Half-Life 1 Kampagne, allerdings, also wie gesagt, ich habe es gestern
schon mal eine halbe Stunde angeguckt, also so, es hat sich schon einiges geändert.
Die haben mehr Gegner, die haben mehr Waffen, die haben angepasste Waffen, die haben teilweise etwas angepasste Level, allerdings sagen sie selbst, die wollen quasi so den, so den Geist des Games erhalten, also wahrscheinlich jetzt nicht super, total abgedreht angepasste Level, aber ein bisschen angepasst sind sie wohl.
Also gestern hab ich zum Beispiel schon gesehen, dass jetzt an manchen Stellen, wo halt im Original Half-Life nix war, jetzt Gegner spawnen und sowas.
Mal gucken. Ne, hab ich nicht. Ich hab keine VR-Brille.
Huch, warum ist das Sound aus?
Moment.
10 hour, brauchen wir das?
Wenn ich ein bisschen erzähle hier.
Spiele ich das heute komplett durch?
Da bin ich mir nicht so ganz sicher.
Ich würde wahrscheinlich, also ich würde prinzipiell gerne.
Also Half-Life 1 ist ein relativ langes Game, wenn man es zum ersten Mal spielt, wenn man es ein paar Mal gespielt hat, kann man durchaus, denke ich mal so in vier Stunden, dreieinhalb, vier Stunden durch sein.
Ich weiß gar nicht, warte mal, Speedrun Half-Life 1, was ist denn der aktuelle Weltrekord? Nicht, dass es jetzt zwei Stunden ist, in denen ich hier irgendwie Mist erzähle.
Okay, ich hab nix gesagt, das müssen wir uns nachher angucken.
Das gucken wir nicht jetzt an, das gucken wir nachher an.
Bin ich mal gespannt, Alter.
26 Minuten.
Okay, also.
Also ich kann mich noch dran erinnern, als ich Half-Life zum ersten Mal gespielt hab.
Guck es gibt neue Waffen und solche Geschichten. Ich glaub das Ding haben sie irgendwie gemoddet aus Opposing Force importiert und sowas.
Also zumindest... Die Musik ist zu laut, was ist da los? Warum?
Ja, ok. Also sie haben, wie gesagt, sie haben wohl einiges gemoddet, das wollte ich nicht sagen.
Also als ich Half-Life 1 zum ersten Mal gespielt habe, also irgendwann 1997, 1998 oder sowas rum,
da habe ich bestimmt eine Woche oder so gespielt, mit ein paar Stunden am Tag, bis ich das erste Mal durch war.
Ich war damals auch mega schlecht, was solche Games anging.
Und man hatte sowas in der Richtung noch gar nicht gespielt.
Und ich glaube, es gibt kein Game, was ich öfters durchgespielt habe als Half-Life 1.
Allerdings ist das ganze auch schon ein bisschen her wo ich zum letzten mal das original gespielt habe und wobei wir gucken wie viel original davon
davon übrigen ich will kein danke für die zahl ich will kein speedrun machen
Mal gucken wie viel vom original noch übrig ist aber sie sagen sie haben sich stark am original
orientiert und auf die frage frage hin ob das wie stark sich das zu black mesa unterscheidet naja der größte unterschied ist also der
Der Obvious Unterschied ist, das ist Half-Life 1 gemoddet und Black Mesa ist Half-Life 1
Quasi etwas moderner nachgebaut in der Source-Engine.
Also das ist schon immer noch Gold-Source-Half-Life-1-Engine, bloß halt gemoddet.
Guck, man kann jetzt weiter zum Beispiel jetzt irgendwie einen Schalldämpfer für die Pistole
und es gibt wohl auch einen extra, extra Feuermodus.
Kann man das Feuermodus nennen? Für das Brecheisen und sowas.
Ja, gibt neue Partikel-Effekte, neue Monster-Typen, oder neue Gegner, sind ja nicht unbedingt Monster, neue Gegner-Typen.
Äh, neue Waffen-Attachments, wie diesen komischen Laser-Pointe an der Shotgun, äh, an dem Revolver und so.
Also sie haben wohl einiges gemacht.
Also sie schreiben selbst, lass mal, ah genau, hier steht's doch, hier ist doch die Übersicht, was die, was die gemacht haben.
Huge thanks für dich, Bartosera-Video.
Ja, das ist mega nice, ich habe hier auch meine Emulator-Kiste stehen.
Da kann man wenigstens mal eine alte Kiste auch neu beleben.
Also ich hoffe, dass ich es heute durchgespielt kriege, wenn nicht, müssen wir die Tage
weitermachen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie...
Also ich glaube, man kann auch als Noob Half-Life durchaus so in 4 Stunden durchspielen.
Ich habe das Original ewig nicht gespielt.
Also das letzte Mal, als ich durchgespielt habe, war tatsächlich...
Black Mesa habe ich auch schon ein paar Mal durchgespielt, allerdings das Original Half-Life 1...
Das habe ich sehr lange nicht mehr gespielt.
Also von Anfang bis Ende, das wirklich lange.
Zehn Jahre vielleicht?
Wobei, nee, kann nicht sein.
Also, ich spiele eigentlich mindestens einmal im Jahr irgendwas Half-Life mäßiges.
Aber die Original-Kampagne in der Original-Engine habe ich schon wirklich eine ganze Weile nicht
mehr gespielt.
Naja, zumindest, sie schreiben mir selbst, was sie gemacht haben, also es gibt...
Ach ja, stimmt, die haben die Waffen wohl auch angepasst, dass die Waffen jetzt zum
größten Teil Projektile schießen und nicht mehr Hitscans sind.
Was wahrscheinlich dem Gameplay ganz gut tut, weil es war ja, also Half-Life 1s Gameplay
war ja eh ein bisschen, aus heutigen Maßstäben zumindest, ein bisschen sehr
klick and shoot halt. Du hast mit dem Fadenkreuz über den Gegner geschossen,
hast halt getroffen. Die Gegner auch, dementsprechend, ach Movement ist jetzt auch
dazu wirklich wichtig. Also sie haben Gunplay überarbeitet, Bullet Spreads,
Rückstoß, hier Optional Non-Hit-Scared Bullets, wir müssen gleich mal in die Options
gehen. Und mal gucken was man da alles einschalten kann. Sie haben die Grafik verbessert, ach
ja und Gordon Freeman hat jetzt Beine, habe ich schon gesehen im Vorschau Video. Man hat
jetzt Beine, also das gab es ja damals noch nicht. Ich bin mir gar nicht mal ehrlich gesagt
Sicher, hatte man in Half-Life 2 überhaupt schon Beine?
Glaub nicht.
Weiß ich gar nicht.
Sie haben die AI ein bisschen verbessert.
Und ganz, oh, ganz, ganz wichtig.
Alle Charaktere blinken jetzt mit den Augen.
Nicht blinken, blinzeln jetzt mit den Augen.
Äh, neue Waffen, neue Waffenanimationen.
Chapter Selection, wir brauchen die Fahrt mit der Bahn nicht zu machen.
Der Waffenmodell überarbeitet neue Animationen, neue Spezialwaffenfunktionen, Silencer, Addons,
also Attachments, Firemodi, Bugs gefixt, bessere Explosionen, Muzzleflashes, alles mögliche.
Also sie haben das Original genommen und so in ihrer Vision verbessert.
Mal gucken.
Also das erste was mir gestern, ich hab gestern das erste, bin ich kurz durchgeflitzt durch
die ersten 1-2 Chapter.
Das geht ja auch sehr zackig.
Es sieht grafisch besser aus als das originale Half-Life.
Ich glaub das kann man sagen.
Aber es ist halt jetzt auch keine Wunder zu erwarten.
Ich mein es ist immerhin noch das originale Half-Life auf der original Gold-Source-Engine.
sind. Na gut, dann gucken wir uns das mal an. Ich mach mal die Musik aus. Gucken wir uns
das ganze mal an. Wir müssen mal schauen, ob, lass mal kurz, hier, Game Screen Capture,
wir müssen mal kurz gucken, ob die Lautstärke okay ist. Und ich muss den, äh, und ich muss
den Fenstermodus ausschalten, weil mit Fenstermodus suckt. Äh, geht das jetzt? Ja, genau, ich
Äh, geht das jetzt?
Ja, doch, ich seh's in der Vorschau, passt alles.
So, wir müssen jetzt gleich mal die Lautstärke checken.
Aber vorher gucken wir uns mal die Optionen an, was man alles so einstellen kann.
Lautstärke müsst glaub ich halbwegs passen.
Also mal gucken.
Also die Half-Life Menü-Sounds waren nie sonderlich gut.
Also, was kann man einstellen?
Okay, Keyboard, alles Standard.
Ich mein Half-Life ist ja das Spiel, was diese ganze WASD-Geschichte mitdefiniert hat.
Ähm, Use Items weiterhin auf E, Swim Up, Swim Down hat eh niemand verwendet.
ist. Control. C. Okay die Musik ist zu laut. Ja wartet mal. Ich mach mal kurz ein bisschen
leiser. Wir müssen gucken wie es ingame ist. Der Menü Sound sagt ja noch gar nichts aus.
Ja ich glaub so ist besser.
Ja WASD-Steuerung gab es schon früher, aber ich, also das erste Spiel an das ich mich
erinnern kann mit WASD-Steuerung, wo ich so bewusst WASD gespielt habe bei Half-Life.
So, Raw Mouse Input, blablabla, achso was mich noch interessieren würde ist, wie macht
man Custom, Custom Weapon Attachments, seht ihr hier irgendwas?
Vielleicht Use mit der Waffe, ohne dass man vor einem Switch steht?
Es müsste ja sowas wie Weapon Attachments oder sowas geben.
Hat der da jetzt irgendwas gesehen?
Ach hier!
Primary Attack, Secondary Attack, Weapon Function ist es wahrscheinlich.
Ok, mittlere Maustaste.
Mittlere Maustaste ist es anscheinend.
Okay, Maus ruhig, Audio lassen wir alles wie es ist, Video lassen wir auch alles wie es ist.
Das lassen wir auch alles so...
Quatsch, das brauchen wir nicht.
Okay, na Moment.
Game-Difficulty stellen wir erstmal auf Hard.
Ich meine, wir sind ja keine Kack-Noobs.
Äh, Kamera lassen wir, ich lasse einfach alles an.
Äh, Texturen, Waffen, Bullets, gut, Fade Corps, das lassen wir aus.
Die dürfen ruhig da bleiben. Ach ja, und es gibt neue.
Und es gibt neue splatter effekte anscheinend
Lasst uns mal kurz
Aber ich gehe mal irgendwo rein und wir müssen mal kurz die lautstärke testen
Ob es ein bisschen laut noch oder
Ich glaube so ist gut
Ich glaube, so ist es ganz gut.
Okay, nice.
Disconnect?
Ja, passt.
Richtiger Boomer-Shooter.
Das ist eines DER Boomer-Shooter schlechthin.
Ach guck mal, jetzt gibt es auch im Menü kein Sound mehr.
Okay, ihr könnt ans Trinken erinnern, ja.
Danke.
Ah, yes.
Okay, ihr könnt euch aussuchen, Chat.
Fangen wir mit Intro-Video an, äh nicht Intro-Video, Intro-Bahnfahrt an oder überspringen wir die Intro-Bahnfahrt?
Ach komm, die dauert 5 Minuten, das können wir uns geben, das gehört irgendwie dazu.
Ich glaub Sound passt so.
Guck mal Barney am Start.
am Start. Vorher müssen wir noch eine andere Sache gucken. Guck mal, den Bug gab es früher
schon, manchmal zumindest. Da gab es zwar nicht dieses Modding Menü, aber der hat teilweise
den Schwierigkeitsgrad nicht richtig mit übernommen. Den Rest hat er aber. Gut, auf geht's.
Oh, wir haben mit dem...
Ich...
Ich hab die Bahnansage kaputt gemacht mit dem Pause drücken.
Ich hab's...
Ich hab's zerstört.
Okay.
Hat er jetzt die schwierigsten Schwierigkeiten...
Alter, was ist das?
Warum ist der Schwierigkeitsgrad immer wieder falsch?
Okay.
Schwierigkeitsgrad immer wieder falsch. Okay, hoffentlich geht die Bahnansage nicht wieder kaputt. Fuck, die ist wieder kaputt!
Kann man vielleicht safen und laden, dass sie wieder geht?
Na gut, der Schwierigkeitsgrad am Anfang ist ja auch egal.
Gib in die Konsole ein Host Framework 0.5 SV Cheats.
Ach Quatsch.
Ist das die selbe Story wie in Half-Life 2?
Nein, das ist die selbe Story wie in Half-Life 1.
Hatte Barney nicht ne Weste früher an?
Mr.
Amec, danke für den Sub.
Was mich früher auch immer wahnsinnig gemacht hat in Half-Life ist, vielleicht erkennt
ihr es.
Ich drücke nicht nach vorne, guck mal, Half-Life-Physics, wenn man springt, fliegt man nach hinten in der Bahn.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr schon mal in der echten Bahn gesprungen seid, aber es ist wie in echt, ne, dann fliegt man auch immer gegen die Wand.
Dachte, das mit dem Zug ist in Half-Life 2. Ja, in Half-Life 2 ist das auch mit dem Zug.
Und weißt du, warum das in Half-Life 2 mit dem, in dem Zug anfängt? Weil Half-Life 1 auch in dem Zug anfange, angefangen hat.
Vielleicht hast du dich auch gewundert, warum das Ende von Episode 2, nee das Ende von Half-Life
Alyx ist es, oder?
Das ist doch auch im Zug.
Und in Half-Life 3 wird es garantiert auch wieder Züge geben.
Du liebst Züge?
Oh ja, da gefällt dir das erste Kapitel in Half-Life auf jeden Fall.
Übrigens, es kann sein, dass wir uns demnächst tatsächlich nochmal ne Runde Half-Life 1
geben müssen, weil ich will ein bisschen Reshading ausprobieren und es gibt ein Raytracing
Leider funktioniert der Raytracing-Mod nicht mit M-Mod.
Guckt euch mal diese High-Res-Textures an.
Ich hab damals recht viel rumgebastelt in dem Half-Life 1 Level-Editor.
Das nannte sich damals noch WorldCraft oder WorldEdit, bin mir nicht mehr ganz sicher und da habe ich auch versucht solche
Ich wusste genau, dass das jetzt kommt. Ist echt der Wahnsinn, wie lange man das nach 20 Jahren noch weiß.
Da habe ich auch versucht, solche Tür-Animationen zu machen, weil ich das so nice fand, wie hier die Türen aufgehen im Tunnel.
Ja, bei mir sieht das Geländer draußen genauso aus.
ist
Kann dings kann einpacken bei den textures hier
Unrecord
Oh das
Leute das hat mich jetzt hart gehittet gerade
wisst ihr was da stand
Gordon Freeman age 27
Als ich das das erste Mal gelesen habe, habe ich mir gedacht, was ein alter Sack.
Und heute bin ich 38.
Ist echt so?
Ich habe damals gedacht, oh der ist aber alt.
Boah, krass, das hat mich jetzt echt getroffen.
Ich muss mal kurz noch die Maus etwas entwirren hier, meine Maus für den Vorschau-Rechner.
Alter, wo geht denn die Maus lang?
Hier unterm Rechner lang?
Sektor C Testlabs
Lass mal kurz, ich muss mal kurz die Maus testen
Ja, geht
Hast du schon graue Haare? Ja
Gordon Freeman hat keine grauen Haare
Wusste sie eigentlich, dass Gordon Freeman ursprünglich eine Brille aufhaben sollte?
Oder sogar auf dem Original-Coverart eine Brille aufhatte?
Bin mir gar nicht so sicher, ob das noch Canon ist.
Ah, da sind wir.
Sektor C, wir sind wieder da.
Hi-Rez-Exit-Schild.
So, jetzt muss ich noch warten, bis die Wache kommt.
von der automatischen Tür zurück und warte, bis der Sicherheitsoffizier verifiziert, dass du im Zug bist.
Bevor du den Zug ausfährst, versichere dich auf die Art und Weise, den Zug zu schützen.
Danke und wünsche dir einen sehr sicheren und produktiven Tag.
Guten Morgen, Herr Freeman. Ich bin zu spät.
Ich muss mal kurz was machen.
Meist gespielte Gameplay. Vielleicht Secret of Mana noch ein Ticken mehr.
Ich konnte euch die Bandansage von der... von der Train wollte ich gerade sagen.
Von dieser Gondel konnte ich fast im Schlaf auswendig.
Aflav 2 hat Brille. Okay.
Okay, ich merke schon den ersten Unterschied.
das
Wobbeln der Kamera das war im original nicht so
All these sounds
Also ich habe ja
oder besser gesagt wir haben ja auch im stream
Black Mesa schon mal gespielt, von Anfang bis Ende.
Und die haben das sehr gut nachgebaut, aber trotzdem, man muss sagen, die Original-Sounds
und die Original-Graphics und so, auch wenn es besser aussieht als das Original, also
ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, was sie gemacht haben, ob sie die Texturen geupdatet haben
Ohne ob sie irgendwie auch noch die...
Ne, die Levels, die sehen genauso aus wie...
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, was sie gemacht haben.
Die Gesichter von den Wachen sehen auch definitiv anders aus als im Original.
Ach übrigens, mal gucken, ob es das Wichtigste noch geht.
Wenn ich den Knopf hier drücke...
Okay, das geht immer noch.
Geht aber nur einmal.
Okay, auf geht's, müssen wir uns einen Anzug holen. Wenn ich das auch richtig im Kopf hab, hier lang, ne?
Yo, hier lang, rechts rum, zack, hier ist die Küche, mit der Mikrowelle, die man kaputt machen kann.
Gordon is a highly trained professional.
Kaputt. So, jetzt können wir noch den Typ auf dem Klo stören, schnell. Der war... ne.
Hier, hier ist der Typ mit dem Klo, genau.
Hat er nicht was gesagt früher?
Ein Ticken lauter können wir es glaube ich machen.
Jeder sagt nicht mehr.
Du hast einfach bis auf 5 oder so alle Zuschauer von Half-Life auf ganz Twitch.
Ja gut, wer streamt auch sonst noch Half-Life?
So, jetzt können wir es mal auf schwer umstellen.
Okay, machen wir mal ein bisschen hinne, sonst wird das heute nichts mit den 4 Stunden.
Wir brauchen unseren Anzug.
So eines der ikonischsten Sachen, glaube ich, in ganz Half-Life.
Zendrix, Dankeschön für die Giftzaps, 5 Stück.
Und blöd für alle, die gedodget haben.
Dodget, easy dodget!
Vegas, danke für den Sub!
So, er geht weiter, Sir. Sieht aus, als wärst du heute in der Kiste.
Defensive Weapon Selection System.
Aktivieren Sie, um die Situation zu erzielen.
Anachronistisch.
Hell yeah, Kekona.
Ok, an dem Level haben sie nicht viel gemacht, aber die Steuerung ist auf jeden Fall weicher.
Aha, es geht immer noch.
Man kann entweder die Leiter klettern oder...
Ihr müsst mal drauf achten, was die in Black Mesa teilweise für total unsinnige Fahrstühle haben.
Das wird auch noch im Laufe des Games auffallen, wer es noch nicht gesehen hat.
gesehen hat. Die sind teilweise sehr ähm...ragwürdig platziert. Und auch von der Funktion her
auch ziemlich bergwürdig. Hello. Musste man damals schon...weiß ich nicht, ich konnte
nie bunnyhoppen in dem game. So, dann gehen wir mal in die Testchamber und lassen uns
erzählen, dass wir ein highly trained professional sind. Auf, move dich, aufmachen.
Der Elektromotor ist auf 105%.
Ein bisschen Gamble, aber wir brauchen die zusätzliche Resolution.
Der Illustrator ist sehr besorgt,
dass wir eine konkrete...
...Konstellation haben müssen.
Die Elektromotoren sind zu etwas zu spät,
um sie zu bekommen.
Und wir müssen sie in der...
...Testgebäude...
Habt ihr das geschafft?
Ich glaube, ja.
Die NPCs so schubsen, dass es schneller geht.
Aber...
keine Ahnung.
Übrigens, die zwei Dudes hier...
Die zwei Dudes, das sind, ähm...
Oder der Dude?
Ne, keine Ahnung. Ich glaube in Half-Life sind die einfach random meist, die Wissenschaftler.
Wobei er hier, er hier nicht.
Ähm, also laut offizieller Half-Life-Story
ist der Wissenschaftler hier
der Typ aus Half-Life 2
und der hier, der nicht so aussieht
der andere ist eigentlich auch der aus Half-Life 2
also die zwei Dudes sind das aus
Half-Life 2
äh, auch wenn die halt überhaupt nicht so aussehen
außer dass er schwarz ist, aber ansonsten
sehen die überhaupt nicht so aus
das ist auch so typisch, guck mal
niemand würde einen
Fahrstuhl an dieser Stelle so dahin bauen. Also die Black Mesa Architekten waren schon echt ein bisschen pp-iger.
Highly trained professional sind wir.
Gordon don't need to hear all of this.
He is a highly trained professional.
Jetzt, wenn ihr die Standard-Insertion-Prozedur folgt...
Habt ihr nicht euren eigenen Job?
Ich weiß nicht, wie man das sagen kann.
Obwohl, ich kann sagen, dass die Möglichkeit einer Resonanz-Kaskade-Szenarie
extrem unnötig ist.
Gordon braucht das nicht zu hören.
Er ist ein sehr trainierter Profi.
Wir haben den Regierungschef versichert, dass nichts schief geht.
Ah, ja.
Du bist ein Profi.
Du hast so viele Jobs in der Welt.
Na dann, lass ihn rein.
aufgefallen, dass die Tür so eine miese Textur hatte früher. Für mich sah das Game damals
einfach nur mega Poggers aus. Ich glaube aber auch nicht, dass die Texturen damals ganz
so verwaschen gewesen sind. Ich glaube, das liegt daran, weil der Mod die ungefilterten
Texturen standardmäßig hat. Was auch nicht verkehrt ist, weil ansonsten sehen die Texturen
einfach nur verwaschen aus.
Du konntest die Texturen auf jeden Fall
filtern lassen und dann dann sahen die
nicht so nicht so pixellig aus aber
halt verwaschen, was im Endeffekt auch
nicht unbedingt besser ist. Egal wir
müssen jetzt uns ein bisschen sputen,
wenn wir das ja heute durchkriegen wollen.
Äh, nee, Moment, das war noch gar nicht so, oder?
Everything's be in order?
Stellzeug, genau!
Wenn wir die Rotoren starten, können wir die Anti-Masspektrometer bis zu 80% erhöhen, bis der Fahrer ankommt.
Echt? Echt? Okay.
Das...
Das, das, das Klettern ist natürlich klar, aber...
Und, und kann ich crouchen?
Moment, kann ich, kann ich crouchen?
Und das geht auch? Moment.
Wartet mal.
Oh!
Guck mal, man kann sogar, man kann sogar crouchen
und es versucht so ein bisschen
zu, zu crouchen.
Now.
Ist das das gleiche wie Plague Mesa?
Ne Plague Mesa ist ein Nachbau hiervon.
Mit leicht anderen Levels.
Wobei ich nicht weiß was sie hier alles angepasst haben.
Also die Partikeleffekte und Lichteffekte sind schonmal besser als 1997.
Nein, es ist gut, wenn es so aussieht.
Verhältnismäßig.
Was passiert eigentlich?
Ich glaube, das habe ich nie ausprobiert.
Oh.
Okay, war damit zu rechnen.
Ich vermute schon, dass sich an der Story nicht viel geändert hat.
Also der Mod
sagt selbst, dass sie versucht haben
Ja, Zen wurde extrem überarbeitet, Zen ist überhaupt nicht wiederzuerkennen in Black Mesa.
Und ich muss auch sagen, auf der einen Seite zum Besseren, auf der anderen Seite aber auch nicht,
weil ich finde, Zen ist in Black Mesa viel zu lang, vor allem die zweite Hälfte von Zen ist viel zu lang gestreckt.
Okay, Explosionen sehen auch besser aus als 1997.
Ja, viel besser!
Kachibas!
Hier habe ich immer versucht, als ich das zum ersten Mal gespielt habe, irgendwie aus diesem Level rauszukommen.
Weil ich gedacht habe, oh da ist die ganze Welt drumherum, da kann man bestimmt raus, aber gut, damals habe ich noch nicht so viel davon verstanden, wie so eine Map aufgebaut ist.
Ich hab gedacht, da geht's weiter, man kann da irgendwie raus.
Es gibt übrigens, im Original gab's nen Bug, da konnte man das Viech hier, wie hießen
die Dinger nochmal, Vortigons oder so, ne?
Man konnte, wenn man sich hier hinstellt beim Spawn von dem Viech, ist es einem auf den
Kopf gefallen und hat überlebt.
Und damit konnte man dann irgendwas klitschen wenn das fisch überlebt hat so genau
Gordon das mit lag hier ist. Er. Hey, highly trained professional
Ich glaube da wird irgendwann auch wiederbelebt wiederbelebt der durch
Ich glaube, wenn man hier ein paar Minuten steht, was wir nicht machen werden, ich glaube, wenn man hier ein paar Minuten steht, dann wird er sogar wiederbelebt.
Machen wir das. Laser!
Okay, man hat schon die neuen Gore-Effekte gesehen.
Und auf jeden Fall neue Feuereffekte.
Wir gehen mal zurück, ob der immer noch wieder...
Guck mal, da ist er!
Ich sag euch, der überlebt, guck!
Mr.
Freeman!
Also, sie haben auf jeden Fall neue Feuereffekte.
So gut sah das im Original nämlich nicht aus.
Aus heutigen Maßstäben wäre natürlich zu sagen, null wehgut, aber ja, das sieht auf
auf jeden Fall besser aus als damals
ach jetzt ist es der richtige Dude
komm mal
großer Dank für den Zap
Das sind die zwei Dudes aus Half-Life 2.
Der hier sieht sich sogar noch ein bisschen ähnlich in Half-Life 2.
Headcrab.
Ja, komm mit.
Oh, der Headcrab-Sound, das ist auch so ein...
Headcrab.
Okay, so krass rumgespuckt haben die Headcrabs aber nicht im Original.
Der ist ja komplett am eskalieren.
Vance und Kleiner, genau. Die zwei hier.
Wie schnell die Ladezeiten sind!
Also SSD ist schon eines der besten Erfindungen der letzten 30 Jahre gewesen.
Also die Half-Life, also das eines der wirklich coolen Sachen damals an Half-Life war ja,
Das ist so eine kontinuierliche, von Anfang bis Ende Level, dass es keine Levelgrenzen im eigentlichen Sinne mehr gab.
Und die Ladezeiten zwischen Levels waren, also zwischen, in diesen Ladegängen und Ladearealen,
die war damals auch schon kurz, aber nicht Millisekunden kurz, wie jetzt.
Arrowchild, danke für den Sub.
M2 größer SSD, äh, das sind beides SSD.
Du meinst M2-SSD größer SATA-SSD?
Oh, das ist eine Headcrab.
Boah, lass mich in Ruhe, ich hab noch nix.
Viel besser sieht das vorher aus als im Original.
Also das hat...
das haben sie gut gemacht.
Jetzt wird gleich die Wache...
die Wache gesplattert.
Achtung!
Gleich gibt es hier Laserstrahl und...
Okay, das haben sie nichts dran geändert.
Das sah im Original auch schon aus.
Übrigens, in der deutschen Version sah das selbstverständlich nicht so aus.
Das ist auch nicht anders.
Okay, es gibt angeblich jetzt einen sekundären Modus für das Brecheisen.
Es gibt auch noch einen primären Modus, einen sekundären Modus, wie heißt denn das, einen
tertiären Modus, wenn man die mittlere Maustaste drückt.
Ah da gibt es, ok, es gibt Fast Attack, Heavy Attack und quasi Ultra Heavy Attack oder sowas.
Okay, das probieren wir gleich mal aus.
Und gleich mal gucken, ob wir die Dinger noch...
Die noch...
Jetzt geht er auch noch.
Wobei, so krass sind die im Original nicht explodiert.
Die sind gesplattert und dann war gut.
Die haben nicht ihren kompletten Körper über die Wand verteilt.
Man kann die mittlere Maus-Taste gedrückt haben.
Ah, I, I, I, I see.
Übrigens, zu dieser, zu dieser Szene,
und ja, ich hab mich über die letzten, äh,
ja, 25 Jahre teilweise etwas zu viel mit Half-Life und Half-Life-Lore und allem drumherum beschäftigt.
Zu dieser Szene hier mit dem Fahrstuhl, ja,
da gibt es sehr fragwürdige fanfiction mehr sage ich dazu jetzt nicht
ich meine gibt es für jedes game
Achtung, Achtung. Bam!
Ne.
Bam!
Okay, nice.
Kann man die jetzt mit einem Schlag splattern?
Wenn man das auflädt?
Boah, come on! Nice!
Lul.
Was passiert, was passiert?
Kann man den auch splattern damit?
Ne, okay.
Okay.
Highly trained professional!
Okay, aufladen, aufladen, aufladen, BÄM!
Oh, das ist ne coole Funktion!
Das mit dem Chargen der Crowbar mag ich!
Das gefällt mir!
So, hier ist glaube ich nix mehr.
Can man die, wir probieren mal was Leute, kann man die im Flug, im Flug...
Ah, fuck.
Moment, das muss ich mal ausprobieren, warte mal.
Ne, geht nicht.
Aber, aber immerhin, einmal hitten und gut ist.
Wollt ich mal ausprobieren
Oh, oh, ein Rechtsklick killt die nicht. Alles klar.
Alter, das sind auf jeden Fall neue Effekte, die sie hier haben, wie die zerplatzen, Alter.
Das war im Original nicht so.
Du konntest die zwar zersplattern, aber die sind nicht durch die komplette Wand geflogen.
Wie? One Hit?
Eigentlich hat man die Pistole hier noch gar nicht, weil man, man, es ist eigentlich nicht gedacht, dass man den Wachmann killt.
Es hat glaube ich keinen spielerischen Sinn, die Gegner zu splattern, wir sind ja nicht in Dead Space.
Aber, aber es geht.
Okay, wir holen uns mal kurz noch ein bisschen Energie von Anzug ab.
Oh, das ist auch nicht im Original drin, ich glaub hier, dass hier Headcrabs und Zombies
sind.
Oh, oh, bisschen voll hier.
Hauen wir uns mal kurz durch.
Zack.
In. Your. Face.
Und wie gut das Sound in Half-Life 1 schon war, man hat den Gegner klarer gehört als in Modern Warfare 2.
Denke ich mir halt so, ey guck mal, in nem Game von 1998 konntest du orten wo Gegner sind.
In nem Game von 2023 denkst du Gegner der rechts neben dir ist, ist unten links neben dir.
über dir. Denkt mal sich auf, wie geht das eigentlich? Wie haben sie das geschafft, dass es...
Hört mal, der ist rechts. Man hört sogar, wie nah er an einem dran ist.
aber das ist nicht nicht mehr möglich 2023
heute schlürfen wir erstmal noch eine runde cola
gut und heute ist eine runde energie und dann geht's los
Okay, das Ding ist leicht unfair platziert.
Wie soll ich denn das hitten?
Geh mal auf Tür.
Tür!
Super, schon runter auf 62.
Jawoll, das hab ich gesucht.
Ja, CS 1.6 war ein Mod für Half-Life, das ist richtig und CS 1.6, es wird euch vielleicht
schockieren, aber CS 1.6 war auch nicht mal ursprünglich CS 1.6, sondern zum Beispiel
auch mal CS 0.5.2.
Also CS war auch mal was vor 1.6.
Also, es gab damals immer Riesendiskussionen, das ist im Prinzip das Gleiche so ein bisschen wie ho-
Was jetzt?
Das ist nicht normal, dass die Tür nicht aufgeht.
Muss ich die Headcrabs splattern vielleicht?
Hoah! Hui!
Nur mal Glück gehabt, ich bin schon instant stuck, weil irgendwas verpackt ist.
Nee, mehr Sachen gab's hier nicht, gell?
Gordon hat übrigens ein Foto vor...
Da gibt es auch irgendeine Story dahinter, wer das Kind auf dem Bild ist.
Ähm, vielleicht von irgendeinem Entwickler oder sowas.
Habe ich aber verdrängt mittlerweile schon.
von einem der entwickler das finde ich das ist eine super neuerung mit der
crowbar das ist das ist eine coole neuerung das gefällt mir jetzt schon
dass man das ding endlich auf auf auf chargen kann
extrem die proge ach die namen der entwickler ist es auf dem spinnt das
Das wusste ich gar nicht.
Das Aufladen der Crowbar finde ich super.
Ich muss mal schauen, ob der nicht immer die...
Ne, der hat Hard-Difficulty eingestellt.
So, jetzt gucken wir uns noch den Dude an.
Konnte man nicht aufmachen und sehen, wie der Typ runterfällt?
Ging doch irgendwie.
Ich bin mir relativ sicher man konnte hier eigentlich aufmachen und sehen wie ein Typ runterfällt.
Au!
Bonkers?
Warum, warum ist gerade die, die halt...
Warum, warum, warum ist gerade die, die halt...
Warum ist gerade das halbe Büro explodiert von einem Fernseher?
Okay, das geht anscheinend nicht mehr.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, man konnte das hier aufmachen und dann ist ein Typ vorne runter gefallen.
Aufschlagen? Meinst du hier?
Ah, so war das!
Und das Ding war auch im Original nicht da.
Und er fällt jetzt runter, wenn man hier drauf geht.
Mehr kann man da nicht machen.
Okay, die Headcrabs sind fies platziert.
Lass uns doch grad mal ausprobieren.
Es gibt doch angeblich jetzt alternative Aufsätze für die.
Stealth-Mode
Stealth-Mode ist im Prinzip das gleiche wie vorher nur einfach mit einem
Schalldämpfer drauf
Alter, PP-Guard
Alter, hier das halbe Büro ist am explodieren gerade
Geb ihm
Bam
Oh, da ist, da ist ja auch noch eine drin
Ah! Ich bin stuck!
Hallo?
Und der hatte im Original glaube ich
einen Windows... Alter!
Warum ist hier an jeder Ecke so eine fucking Headcrab?
Ähm... Ich glaube der hatte
im Original einen Windows Plus Screen
eigentlich vor sich.
Und nicht so einen...
einen Laptop, aber zumindest kann man ihn killen, indem man den Bildschirm killt.
Bilde ich mir einen.
Ja, genau.
Genau.
Ah, endlich ordentlich Munni.
Und es gibt nen Bug. Mal gucken, ob der hier auch auftritt.
Ich glaube aber den haben sie gefixt.
Man konnte, wenn man jetzt saved, glaube ich, und wenn man wieder reinlädt...
Nee. Irgendwie ging das. Dann hat der Wachmann einfach überlebt.
Die Opposing Force-Zange.
Wer zu...
Ähm, ich glaub wir haben den Trigger kaputt gemacht.
Genau, weil normalerweise wird der Typ, der da liegt, da reingezogen von irgendeinem Alien
und ich glaub wir haben mit unserem Save-Laden grad ein bisschen den Trigger kaputt gemacht.
So und jetzt versetzt euch mal in mich rein, wenn ihr das Game zum ersten Mal spielt, ihr
seid, lasst mal überlegen, 1997, äh ich bin 1994 und da war ich 13 oder sowas. Könnt ihr euch vorstellen,
dass wenn man das zum ersten Mal ungeschnitten spielt, dass man da ein bisschen Schiss hat
als 13-Jähriger, wenn man sowas noch nie gespielt hat? Also ich hatte auf jeden Fall
ein bisschen Schiss, gerade so in den ersten paar Levels. Danach wird ja Half-Life auch
sehr actionlastig.
Wie ich nur weiß, dass die Dinger vier Hits brauchen, lul.
Ja, seeh.
Guck mal, der G-Man am Start, weg, weg da.
Was ist eigentlich alternativer Feuermodus von der Pistole?
Die schießt jetzt langsamer?
Wait.
Hä?
Normalerweise ist der Sekundärfeuermodus von der Pistole, dass sie schneller schießt, jetzt schießt sie langsamer im Sekundärfeuermodus.
Das Ding, da steht 100 pro auf!
So das müssen wir jetzt splattern, das steht 100 pro Aufsonst.
Wow!
bessere feuereffekte
mitkommen
da gibt es nämlich handgranaten gleich wenn man den hier hinten hin führt
ja das hast du recht es war im original nicht so dass man so schnell
also schnell schießen konnte wie man geklickt hat
Grenades, exzellent!
Und Toastbrot
was man nicht
kaputt machen kann
Achtung, muss sein jetzt
Okay, weiter
Jetzt wird das Tor gleichzeitig
zerdrömmert?
Nicht?
doch das Tor wird zertrümmert
kanns sein
machen mehr Damage
die Viecher machen mehr Damage
ich glaube die haben auch ein bisschen was am Schwierigkeitsgrad getunt
oder
ich sacke einfach nur
jetzt kommt der Typ in der Kiste
Schreckt
Lagen im original auch die magazine rum wenn man die rausgeworfen hat
Ich glaube fast nicht
Ja auch
Da muss man sich aber ganz schön anstrengen die zu treffen
Erstmal alles clearen
Weil wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe
Erinnerungen habe
Alter, was ist hier los?
Wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe, müssen wir hier vorschwimmen
Genau, hierhin müssen wir. Einmal unten durch
Aufmachen, dann steigt das Wasser
Nee, nee, nee, nee. Hier, hier müssen wir lang
Genau, hier müssen wir lang.
Warnigkels machen mehr Damage.
Ist ja auch eigentlich richtig so, weil die Dinger haben ja im Original überhaupt nichts gebracht.
Entweder die haben dich eingesaugt und nicht mal richtig schnell gekillt.
Oder du bist halt dran vorbeigelaufen.
Erstmal splattern, wer weiß, ob die Dinger wieder aufstehen.
stehen
Die halten aber dick aus
Das sind wirklich projektile leute guckt mal guckt mal das sind die meine schüsse das ist kein hitscan mehr seht ihr das seht ihr das
das sind projektile das war im original definitiv nicht so seht ihr das die
fliegende die fliegenden stück das ist das ist das ist hundertprozentig neu dass
die schüsse fliegen und nicht inszenierten und man sieht man sieht die
man sieht die schüsse ja man sieht die schüsse sogar fliegen
Das ist auf jeden Fall nicht so gewesen.
Boah, da muss man aber richtig triggern, dass man die rechtzeitig kaputt kriegt.
Und jetzt, und jetzt kletschen wir das Ganze mal ein bisschen.
Okay, das geht immer noch, alles gut.
Genau!
Reflexible Links geht das auch, das hab ich mir auch gemerkt.
Man konnte einfach runtersliden anstatt sich hier, weil normalerweise wenn man hier in
der Mitte ist, kommen jetzt laufend irgendwelche Headcrabs runtergeslided und versuchen sich
da zu killen drauf.
Just Half-Life-Physics.
Und hier kann man jetzt runtersliden und alles ist gut.
Und wenn man rechts runterslidet kommen keine Headcrabs anscheinend.
Sehr merkwürdig.
Vielleicht...
Vielleicht muss man durch irgendeinen so speziellen Trigger durch.
Ne, es kommen gar keine Headcrabs.
Normalerweise kommen Headcrabs hier...
... runter.
Na gut.
Eines der besten Games. Hast du das Gameplay gemäß...
Ja, wir haben sogar im Stream durchgespielt.
Als es...
Als es auf Steam rausgekommen ist.
Hallo?
Wie jetzt?
Willst du mich rollen oder wie?
Dafür wird er, dafür wird er Crowbarred
Oh, oh, oh
Jetzt aber
Ah
What the
Wie viele Handgrabs hat der Typ hier am Start
Wo ist das Viech?
Wo ist denn das Vieh hin?
Da
So
Und wenn ich es noch irgendwie richtig in Erinnerung habe
Dann ist hier glaube ich auch ein bisschen Muni und sowas drin
In den Kisten
Übrigens sehr praktisch
Dass die Crowbar jetzt einen alternativen Feuermodus hat
Weil ansonsten musste man Kisten immer so öffnen
Guck
immer so öffnen. Guck!
Und dann ist es irgendwann kaputt gegangen.
Das wurde mit der Zeit nervig, weil
eins muss man ihnen ja in Half-Life
ja, ein bisschen
vielleicht ein bisschen negativ angreifen. Wenn sie
nicht wussten, was... Wups!
Spiel außerdem geclosed.
Wenn sie nicht wussten, was sie hinsetzen sollten,
dann haben sie einfach Kisten hingesetzt.
Es scheint mir fast so, als hätten
hätten die Entwickler von Battlefield 2042 zu viel Half-Life gespielt, weil die haben
auch überall Kisten hingesetzt.
Ja, gerade in der zweiten Hälfte des Games sind die Kisten relativ schnell kaputt zu
machen.
Ich glaube, das ist den Entwicklern aufgefallen oder sie hatten einfach keinen Bock mehr im
Level Editor die Kisten irgendwie die Hälfte zu setzen und haben sie auf 1 gelassen.
Jetzt aber, ALTER, die Handgrabs sind ja ultra krass drauf in dem Mod, wo gehts denn hier
lang?
Oh, Achtung, ausholen, ausholen
BÄM
Es war ursprünglich kein Zeugs in den Kisten
Erst nach Playtest wurde das geändert
Also
Da kann ich mir gut vorstellen
Wie lange dauert ein Speedrun 26 Minuten
Oh, sind wir hier
Dann müssen wir uns beeilen
das Fisch out of headcrabs ist auf der anderen Seite
also Speedrun Weltrekord ist 26 Minuten 30 oder sowas
wir haben vorhin geguckt
oh oh
das ist jetzt ein bisschen doofe Situation hier gerade
Den müssen wir ein bisschen cheesen.
Au!
Heiß. GG Eats. Und uns splattern.
Das macht mega Bock, die Viecher zu zersplattern.
Und das ging auf jeden Fall im Original nicht so schön.
Ja, eine Sache, die...
Sag mal, wie viel hältst du aus?
Okay, Dead Gear.
Also eine Sache, die mir im Original damals auch aufgefallen ist,
wie viele unsinnige Teile immer in den Kisten drin waren.
Aber anscheinend sind hier keine Teile drin.
Da sind immer so Disketten und CDs und Festplatten und Spritzen
und so komisches Zeug ist da immer aus den Kisten rausgefallen.
Was du nicht aufheben konntest, was irgendwie zur Atmosphäre beitragen sollte, aber eher weird gewesen ist.
Und diese Headcrabs hier, die hat auf jeden Fall der Modgetyp platziert. Die gab es glaube ich so im Original auch alle nicht.
Und hier in dem Raum gab es auch relativ sicher keine Gegner.
Finde ich aber, finde ich tatsächlich ganz gut, weil das war so, das war tatsächlich hier ein Teil von Half-Life, den empfand ich damals, wie gesagt, ich hab das Spiel irgendwie 35 mal durchgespielt oder so, empfand ich relativ langweilig, so die, so die...
So, sag mal so, nach dem Intro, bis dann ein bisschen mehr passiert, da war so ne, war ein Übergang, der war nicht so, war halt nix los, ja.
Hier war halt gar nichts im Original, ich glaube keine Headcrabs, keine Wartiguns, keine Zombies, nix.
Und ein Ding was Source Games bis heute noch haben, du hast das 35 mal durchgespielt, bestimmt, locker.
Ich hab das Game, Leute. Ich bin... Ich...
Bestimmt. Also ich hab das Game mir damals gekauft, sogar.
Äh, okay, das wollte ich jetzt erzählen.
Also, das erste Mal, als ich das Spiel gespielt hab, hab ich's natürlich gespielt, wie man das damals 1997 so üblich,
hat man sich das irgendwie geshared zwischen Leuten halt.
über
Entweder über BNC-Netzwerkkarten oder noch über Nullmodem-Kabeln oder über irgendwelche selbstgebrannten CDs oder sowas
So, aber dann wollte ich irgendwann... Oh, hier spawnen jetzt Gegner
Das war im Original auch nicht so
Hast du es hier nicht im Mediamarkt gekauft? Das kann sogar sein, ich weiß es gar nicht mehr genau, wo ich das gekauft habe
Zumindest ich habe das Spiel allein schon irgendwie zehnmal durchgespielt oder so, da hatte ich das Spiel noch nicht mal gekauft
So und dann habe ich es mir gekauft und dann hatte ich die deutsche version weil es gab bei mir halt nur die deutsche version zu
Kaufen und das war mit robotern
Und sicherheitsleuten die sich auf den boden gesetzt haben wenn sie gekillt wurden
Und der grund warum ich mir dann irgendwann gekauft habe ist weil ich online spielen wollte und um online spielen zu können
hast du
Sterben, please. Oh, ich hab keine Schuss mehr.
Um online spielen zu können, hast du einen gültigen CD-Key gebraucht.
Das war noch der Vorgänger...
Oh, shit.
Ich muss mich beeilen. Ich hab keine...
Ich hab keine Muni mehr.
Ich hau mal kurz ab.
Um online... Also das war so quasi noch der Vorgänger von Steam damals.
Ich glaube, das hieß irgendwas mit... mit net.
Immer noch ne Ahnung, wie das hieß.
Irgendwas nett, weh nett, wie ist das original, woll nett oder sowas, der originale Online Service von Half-Life.
Zumindest hat man damals, dass man sich überhaupt online einloggen konnte, einen gültigen CD-Key gebraucht.
Mensch, also, der Mod-Ersteller hat es mit den Headcrabs aber übertrieben.
Head, Headcrab-Geh
Und die hatten damals halt noch so keinen richtig guten
Ja, keine, keine richtig, damals gab es noch keinen guten Online-Zwang, nennen wir es mal so
Aber du hast halt einen gültigen CD-Key gebraucht, um online spielen zu können. So einen gültigen CD-Key zu finden
war gar nicht so schwierig, also damals konnte man
Damals konnte man schon im Internet suchen nach Half-Life CD-Keys
Und hat welche gefunden. Leider hat man damals nur so generierte CD-Keys gefunden, die halt online nicht richtig funktioniert haben.
Und manchmal hat man allerdings, frag mich nicht wie die in Umlauf gekommen sind, manchmal hat man CD-Keys gefunden, die gültig waren.
So und das dumme war, die haben damals in dem Online-Service das so gemacht, der Letzte, der sich mit dem CD-Key einloggt, darf spielen.
Das heißt, wenn ich mich eingeloggt habe mit dem CD-Key,
habe ich den Originalbesitzer des CD-Keys rausgeschmissen,
dann hat er sein Spiel neu gestartet, hat sich eingeloggt, hat mich wieder rausgeworfen.
Das war dann teilweise stundenlanger War, wer gibt zuerst auf beim CD-Key-Usen.
Hahaha.
Und irgendwann hatte ich dann keinen Bock mehr
und habe mir so gedacht, ey, weißt du was, kauf dir doch das Spiel einfach.
Dann hab ich meine Mutter dazu überredet, mit mir wahrscheinlich in den Mediamarkt oder sowas
Weiß gar nicht mehr was ich...
Wahrscheinlich Mediamarkt oder sowas
Irgendwo in der Richtung zu fahren und Half-Life zu kaufen
Und die war damals halt auch schon so ein bisschen skeptisch, was so...
Ich mein mit 13 so Spiele, ab 18 und so
Wow
Monka
Wollte die erst nicht
Aber ich hab sie lange genug belabert
Okay nice
Ich hab sie lange genug belabert und irgendwann hat sie mir das halt dann trotzdem gekauft und dann hatte ich einen ersten gültigen Half-Life 1
Mein Half-Life 1 CD-Key
What?
Da ist überhaupt nix
Hier...
Hier ist überhaupt nix
Guck mal
Da...
Da ist nix
Was ist das?
Bakke
Vielleicht von der Seite?
Sag mal, ist das G-Bait, dass man das nicht bekommen kann?
Ich bin geduckt.
Okay, ich bin geduckt an der Wand.
Hier ist nix.
Alter!
Was hat das Ding für eine übertriebene...
Okay, vielleicht müssen wir einfach nur schnell sein.
Ventil?
Welches Ventil?
Es gibt kein Ventil, was man kaputt machen kann.
Man kann ja nix kaputt machen.
Kann man das rausschießen?
Ne, wir sind ja nicht in Half-Life 2.
Man kann auch den Ventilator nicht kaputt machen.
Zumindest wäre mir das neu, wenn man den Ventilator kaputt machen kann.
Okay.
Achtung!
Ah!
Leute!
Das ist bestimmt der...
Man hat ne größere Hitbox, wenn man crouched ist.
Passt mal auf!
Wenn ich nicht crouched bin...
ich fürchte ich fürchte wir müssen das liegen lassen kommt man nicht dran
kommt man vielleicht so rum dran
easy sehr merkwürdige geschichte aber okay
Also die Hitboxen sind schon ein bisschen pepega hier gerade.
What the?
Komm ich jetzt nicht mehr raus oder wie?
Okay, ah, jetzt, der schwerste Gegner im ganzen Spiel wird das jetzt wahrscheinlich sein
rückblickend.
Also das war im Original definitiv nicht so schwierig, vielleicht ist Gordon einfach nur zu fett geworden, ja.
Pipo Fett, Highly Trained Professional.
Saved.
Safe-ge.
Da ich erstmal Cola rein.
Safe-Geh!
Ich bilde mir eine, hinten gab es auch noch eine, ja.
Eins, zwei, drei, vier.
Man braucht, man braucht glaube ich diese Scientist hier drinnen gar nicht, die sind glaube ich normalerweise gescriptet von den Dingern gekillt zu werden.
So, jetzt ist der Strom hier aus, jetzt können wir hier rein.
Oder auch nicht.
Ah, so war das.
So, da müssen wir lang.
überlangen wenn ich das richtig in erinnerung habe kriegt man aber noch eine shotgun vorher irgendwo hier
Erst mal randalieren in das schöne 19 zoll rack
Schau mal, Chargen. Bäm! Ey, das ist nice. Das hätt's auch im Original gebraucht. Das
find ich extrem satisfying Technik hier. Das Chargen von der Crowbar. Und auch das Zersplattern
von den Gegnern. Das sieht jetzt viel besser aus.
Bäm!
So, hier gab es glaube ich neben eine Shotgun.
Guck, manche
Pisten sind witzigerweise
mit ein paar Hits kaputt.
Und manche brauchen eine halbe Stunde.
Und das ist wieder eine fies
Platziert der Headcrab
Ja Shotgun, wusste ich doch
Nice
Pogu
Erstmal die Hälfte
Ins Metall geklatscht
58 damit kann ich ja das halbe game durchspielen mit 58 Shotgun Shells
Da steht immer was von Stealth wenn man den Gegner zerstört
Ne das ist wenn ich die Pistole in die Hand nehme
Die Pistole hat die Stealth Modification
Guck, wenn ich den Schalter einfach abschraube, dann ist es die, dann ist der Combat-Mode.
Meine Vermutung ist ja, ich hab mir die Stats von, ich hab mir die Stats natürlich nicht angeguckt,
meine Vermutung ist, dass es gibt überhaupt keinen Unterschied dazwischen,
es ist einfach nur für Leute, die sich cooler finden, wenn sie Silenced-Pistole haben.
Ich vermute mal, Statist, Statistiks ist überhaupt kein Unterschied.
Korrekt.
so
jetzt müssen wir durch das
elektronifizierte
elektrifizierte
au
Zimmer durch
äh
ah Lichtschalter
genau
und hier waren Headcrabs drinne wenn man einfach
unvorsichtig rein rennt
ich find's immer noch geil
Leute oh
Ob es drei waren im Original, weiß ich nicht.
Ich finde es teilweise immer noch lustig, dass ich Headcrab-Positionen kenne.
Und hier ist jetzt ein Lüfter.
Und wenn man, wenn man nicht gecrouched läuft, passiert folgendes.
Da hab ich, da kann ich, also, wisst ihr, warum ich mir das so gut gemerkt hab?
Das erste Mal, das kann ich mich heute noch dran erinnern.
Das erste Mal, als ich das Game gespielt hab, hab ich nicht aufgepasst.
Und ich lauf durch den Gang und BÄM, ich sterb auf einmal. Ich hab mich mega erschreckt.
Wisst ihr, das war wirklich so ein Moment, so dumdumdum, boah!
Ich hab mich eh, als ich das Spiel das erste Mal gespielt hab, bei einigen Sachen übelst erschreckt.
13-jähriger Max, ich mein, das beste Beispiel dafür ist ja, dass Gordon, ich hab's ja euch ja im Intro erzählt,
dass Gordon Freeman 27 ist in dem, in dem Game.
Und als ich das im Intro gelesen hab, als ich 13 war, dachte ich mir halt so,
Dachte ich mir halt so, lul, Alter, 27, ganz schön alter Typ.
Die Headcrabs sind ziemlich aggressiv in dem Mod.
Der Half-Life 2 S-Mod hat teilweise Jumpscares.
Find ich, passt nicht so richtig zu Half-Life.
So, Half-Life ist ja kein Horror-Game in dem Sinn, Half-Life hat so ein bisschen
halt dichte Atmosphäre, aber jetzt nicht so dieses, das ist ja kein Amnesia oder sowas.
Aber ich find's cool, dass man Füße hat jetzt.
Wo ist die Headcrab?
Die Headcrabs sind in dem Mod wirklich brutal drauf.
Äh, hier kommen wir doch grad her.
Ey! Anzeige ist raus. Einfach nochmal durchkrabbeln.
Wer hat sich als Kind nicht bei Ravenholm ins höchste gewandert?
Da war ich schon ein bisschen älter. Half-Life, wann kam Half-Life 2 raus?
Half-Life 2 kam 2004 oder so raus, gell?
Da war ich dann schon ein bisschen älter, da war ich quasi 6 Jahre alt, da war ich 19.
Da hab ich mich nicht mal ganz so eingeschossen bei Games.
Hier kann man jetzt zurück.
Ist ja gut Mensch.
Da ist übrigens gerade, falls ihr euch fragt was da ballert, da ist so ein Sentry Gun die
Headcrabs zerlegt.
Und man muss normalerweise einfach außerhalb der Sicht stehen bis die einfährt und wenn
die einfährt kann man sie kaputt machen.
Aber ich glaub die...
Jetzt fährt sie ein.
So, und wenn die einfährt, kann man sich volle Pulle hinrennen.
Uaah!
Okay, geschafft, geschafft, geschafft. Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Alles gut.
Schalter aus.
Hm.
Wie kommt man da hoch?
Jump, äh, äh,
Jump, crouch, crouch, jump.
Jump. Funktioniert nicht. Wie kommt man da hoch? Wahrscheinlich gar nicht. Nein, es gibt
keine kleine Kiste. Gibt es eine kleine Kiste hier irgendwo? Keine, die man schieben kann.
Weil es ist, es ist kein, es ist kein... Ach hier! Alter, Six Head Time! Ich glaube, das
habe ich noch nie Half-Life Kistenphysics. Das habe ich glaube ich noch nie gemacht.
Die Kistenphysics sind so geil, Alter. Guckt euch die Kisten... Alter. Kistenphysics. Jetzt
kommt man hier ran. Deswegen kann man zurück. Siehste? Sogar ich entdecke heute noch neue Sachen in Half-Life.
Ich wusste, ich, das war mir bis jetzt glaube ich gar nicht, ich glaube ich habe das noch nie gemacht hier hoch mit der kleinen Kiste.
Mit der, dass man mit der kleinen Kiste übelst rum klitschen kann, kann ich mir vorstellen, ja.
Generell ist Half-Life 1, wir gucken uns zum Schluss, entweder wenn wir durch sind oder wenn ich, wenn es zu, wenn es zu lange dauert,
Gucken wir uns noch den speedrun an 25 minuten. Das wird glaube ich komplett
Mind das mind blowen wieder ich kenne ja half life speedruns die waren früher schon krass, aber ich glaube mittlerweile sind die noch abgedrehter
Hier oben ist jetzt noch eine sentry gun. Nee, ne? Nicht? Naja anscheinend nicht
Brauch ammo, sorry
Oh, Headcrab!
Office-Komplex! Jawoll!
Jetzt brauch ich meine Shotgun. Gegen die Viecher ist die Shotgun-Pock.
Oh no!
Man kann nichts daran ändern.
Hört ihr übrigens die Gegner um mich drumherum?
Ja? Ihr hört die Gegner, ne?
Und ihr hört die Gegner links neben mir
und ihr hört die Gegner rechts neben mir.
Und ich frag mich halt so, ey guck mal
das ist ein Game von 1997
und man kann ohne Probleme orten
wie viele Gegner in welcher Richtung sind
und wie weit weg.
Und da guckt man sich Call of Duty Vanguard
Vanguard oder sowas an oder oder mw1 mw2 also die die remakes und denkt so ey guck mal der typ kam jetzt von rechts die treppe
Hochgelaufen ich habe nichts gehört oder du denkst dir ich habe was gehört aber da kann doch eigentlich von links unten oder sowas
Durch die wände hören ist nicht realismus
Aber aus der falschen richtung gegner hören ist auch kein realismus also die technik war ja offensichtlich ist ja ist ja offensichtlich da
Ich finde die Shotgun ist die langweiligste Waffe in ganz Half-Life.
Das Ding macht zwar im Melee-Range richtig gut Damage, aber die anderen sind schon deutlich
innovativer gewesen.
Also guck mal mit der Pistole mal außen vor. Also Half-Life hatte ja eigentlich nur drei so richtig, so richtig
klassische Shooter-Waffen. Du hast eine Pistole, du hast eine SMG und du hast ein Shotgun.
Der Rest ist ja alles schon mit ein bisschen Trick. Ja, du hast den, du hast dann den, du hast den, den Bogen, äh, nicht den Bogen, ähm,
die Armbrust hast du später, dann hast du dieses Laser-Ding,
diese kleinen Aliens, die du werfen kannst, diese Statue-Charges und sowas.
Die hatten alle schon, aber die Shotgun finde ich so das langweiligste.
Hier die Range ist nicht so gut für die Pistole hier.
Guck ich hör jetzt auch, dass rechts hier irgendwas rumläuft noch an Aliens.
Irgendwo...
Wow!
Haben wir...
Sind wir echt noch auf schwer?
Das ist viel zu easy.
Eats?
Oh, da ist was. Da kletscht was durch die Wand.
Wie, das hat... Ja, klar!
Der Typ hat einfach gerade drei Shotgun-Sekundärfeuer überlebt.
Normalerweise überleben die ein Doppel-Doppeltreffer.
Treffer
Vielleicht war es doch Monkey S.A. im Jahr, kann auch sein
Vielleicht hab ich die Hälfte vorbeigeschossen
Topmehr war hier nicht
Topmehr gab es hier nicht mehr
Ne
Oh! Da ist ja noch was! Ich hab gerade in den Chat gelesen. Nope, nicht schnell genug.
Was, am Donnerstag gab es bei uns in der Uni eine Gastvorlesung von Leuten von Denovo.
Äh, Denuvo. Sind das nicht die Kopierschutz-Dudes?
Na klar, das hält die Kiste aus. Easy.
Kiste aus Stahl.
Oh, da oben ist die Sentry-Gun gewesen. Ja, hier musste man schnell sein.
Oh! Guck mal, die Sentry-Gun ist noch mit den Headcrabs beschäftigt. Wir rennen einfach schon weiter. Easy.
Hallo!
Was will denn das Viech?
Da bin ich mir auch nicht sicher, ob es diesen Raum überhaupt gab im Original.
Ich war hier glaube ich noch nie drin.
Angranaten. Oh gut.
Oh.
Ja das hat's
jetzt ja richtig gebracht. Ich bin
Ich hab Leben verloren, der Wachmann ist
dead und ich hab nix dafür bekommen, was
ich lohnt. Nice. Sehr gut.
Wahrscheinlich gab's das wegen dem Raum im Original nicht.
Oder gab's den?
Keine Ahnung. So, so
Wie gesagt, es ist lange her, wo ich zuletzt gespielt habe.
Mehr Headcrabs.
In dem Kurs lernen wir Software-Protection-Maßnahmen kennen.
Eben für DRM und sowas passt denen aber echt gerne.
Ja gut, ich meine, ich verstehe schon, dass die in die Uni gehen,
die Uni gehen, weil die müssen ihren Kram hier irgendwie loswerden.
Und das ist besser,
als wenn die Leute schon mal mit
sowas in Kontakt gekommen sind.
Es ist ähnlich
dazu, warum Office und Photoshop
und sowas in der Schule auch so beliebt ist.
Und die auch überhaupt nichts dagegen haben,
dass denen billiger zu verkaufen, weil ganz ehrlich,
jemand der nur Office kennt oder nur Adobe
Produkte kennt, der wird halt auch nichts anderes benutzen.
Hast du eigentlich auch mal
Serious Sam gespielt? Klar.
Alle?
Nee, nicht alle. Das stimmt nicht.
Das stimmt nicht. Ich hab nicht alle gespielt.
Das letzte hab ich nicht gespielt.
Wobei das glaube ich ganz okay sein soll sogar.
Allerdings bisschen unfertig.
Benutzt du auch Office?
Ja, leider.
Von Serious Sam kommt dein Name.
Aha.
Modgil. Modgil Name Reveal.
Ah, jetzt kommt das Kühlhaus.
Guck mal, da gibt's Fleisch für die Veganer.
Ja, Brokkoli.
Was ich ja witzig finde, ne?
Wenn du Kisten mit Fleisch splatterst, kommt was raus.
Wenn du Kisten mit Gurken splatterst, kommen keine Gurken raus.
Äh, nee, ich glaube ...
Erwischt!
Und diese hängenden Dinger hier konnte man glaube ich auch kaputt machen.
Mir ist nicht aufgefallen, dass die glänzende Oberflächen haben.
Hatten sie wahrscheinlich im Original auch nicht.
Genauso physikalisch korrekt.
Falls ihr mal in irgendeinem LKW seid mit so einer Brechstange und dagegen haust, dann schneidet es auch beim Hit so die Kuh einmal schräg durch.
Jetzt aber.
Ich glaube ich verwende... Ey!
Ich glaube, ich verwende lieber die Pistole dafür, weil ich haue viel zu viel Shotgun-Ammo raus gerade.
Ja, dafür hätte es die Shotgun gelohnt.
So, wie ging es hier weiter? Man musste hier oben hin.
Wenn ich das noch richtig im Kopf... Okay, erstmal hier das anmachen.
Ja, genau, das ist das Band. Hier oben drüber musste man dann.
Ich glaube ich glaube das ich glaube das fährt jetzt die ganze zeit hin und her
Ja genau jetzt musste man irgendwie hier hoch
Wenn ich nur wüsste wo das rauf geht
Hier ist ein dat gewachmann
hier ist
muni
Wo gehen das hier noch mal rauf hier hier easy
Bestimmt bestimmt volle Headcrabs die die Luftschächte
Ja genau so war das über das teil drüber
Power 20%
Power 30%
Erstmal, Erstmal die Security Guards splattern, jawoll, Next!
Ah, was ist das, da kann ich mich gar nicht mehr dran erinnern.
An den Raum kann ich mich nicht mehr erinnern.
Hallo, please spring.
Lebt es noch?
Okay, typischer Half-Life-Moment, Luftschacht gegrabbelte.
Ich glaub, wenn die Leute an eine Sache bei Half-Life denken, also, neber den offensichtlichen
und dann ins Luftschacht gegrabbeln.
Ja, guck, da sind schon welche.
Nop.
Aber nicht mit uns.
Ah ja, und die Lampe, die geht aus mit der Zeit.
Und
eigentlich
hatte man nicht normalerweise unten rechts im Original noch ne
Ach ne, oben rechts ist es. Oben rechts sieht man den Akku, den Akku von der Lampe.
Oben rechts war das.
Ist der blind?
Okay, schauen wir mal, ob hier noch irgendwie ein bisschen Ammo und Shield oder sowas drin
ist und ansonsten, let's go!
Ey, jetzt kommt das mit dem Aufzug, glaube ich.
Warte mal hier.
Na geh man!
aufzug stellt
hello der
weil du hättest auch einfach weg rennen können
Ich muss mehr die Granaten benutzen. Ich bin jetzt schon in zwei Räume gekommen, wo Granaten rumlagen, aber ich komplett voll mit Granaten war.
Woah! Leiterphysics.
Man kann den Typ übrigens retten.
Man kann über den Trigger drüber springen.
Ich glaube nicht, dass ich es jetzt hinbekomme.
Aber man kann über diesen Runterfalltrigger drüber springen und dann hängt er für immer im Luftschacht.
Ich weiß, ich weiß nicht genau, wo der Trigger ist, dass der runterfällt.
Ich glaube, wenn man hier, wenn man hier über die, hier an der Leiter hochgeht...
Okay, probieren wir mal. Mal gucken, ob ich das hinkriege.
Ne.
Ne, okay, kriege ich nicht hin.
Bäm!
Wie?
Dacht ihr den zerlegt es jetzt komplett?
Grenade Swap als Hotkey!
Das ist ja...
Grenade Swap als Hotkey
Stimmt ja du hast Recht
Das ging ne
Du konntest einstellen
Last Weapon oder?
Du konntest nicht explizit nen Granatenwerf Knopf machen
Du konntest Last Weapon einstellen
Und dann konntest du quasi Swappen
Wenn du Granate ausgewählt hast
Hier Last Weapon
Q
Da konntest du Granate auswählen und Shotgun
Dann konntest du quasi schnell rein Swappen
Ja gut, du meinst, du kannst auch 5 drücken.
Meiner Meinung nach, ist das das coolste Level oder zumindest das, wo ich immer dran denken muss aus Half-Life, also dieses Level und das angrenzende.
So dieses, wo zum ersten Mal die Soldaten kommen und sowas.
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wie das jetzt genau ging, ob man da...
Okay, das war ne blöde Idee.
Warum schießt denn das drei Stunden?
Ah!
Outplayed.
Hier gab es schon die MP5?
Die MP5 hat angeblich jetzt auch einen alternativen Silencer-Attachment.
Ist natürlich viel cooler mit einem Silencer die Gegner zu killen.
Achtung!
Bam!
Und...
Nix drin, da hat's schon mal voll gelohnt.
Ich war übrigens damals, als ich das zum ersten Mal gespielt...
...oder...
...die ersten Male, wo ich das gespielt hab...
...war ich übrigens richtig pepega.
Ich habe ganz lange nicht gecheckt, dass...
...die Pistole...
...und die MP5...
...die gleiche Munition verwenden.
Dass die beide die 9mm...
...ähm...
...Rounds benutzen.
Und ich hab mich immer gefragt...
Wenn ich mit der, wenn ich mit der MP5 gespielt habe, warum meine Pistole immer leer ist.
Das Konzept von Ammo-Typen war mir damals einfach nicht klar.
Und das muss ich mal ausprobieren, ob das noch geht. Also,
gewollt will das Game, dass man drüber springt, aber man konnte auch früher, man konnte auch...
Ey, das geht immer noch!
Man kann es sich auch draufstellen.
Also, wie man sieht, ich stehe offensichtlich gerade auf der Mine an der Wand, logischerweise.
Nicht irgendwo anders.
Also, man sieht es an den Füßen, dass ich eindeutig auf der Mine stehe.
In den USA hätte ich das gewusst, ja.
Was? In den USA? Ja.
Gut, in den USA hätte ich aber wahrscheinlich auch immer eine Pistole dabei,
Falls einer auf mein Grundstück gerannt kommt, dass ich den instant abknallen kann.
Ey!
Alter!
Das Gunplay fühlt sich viel nicer an als im Original.
Also,
dass die hier, dass die Schüsse
tatsächlich Projektile sind
und der Sound
mit dem Schalldampfer drauf finde ich auch angenehmer.
Gucken, ob sie was am Originalsound geändert haben. Mal kurz testen.
Nö.
Ist aber noch das gleiche. Klick, klick, klick.
Hm.
Wie machte man das auf?
Machte man das überhaupt irgendwie auf? Lüftungsschacht oder so?
Irgendwie, irgendwie auf hier oben drauf, auf dem Lüftungsschacht, oder?
Egal! Nicht, dass wir die, die, die Munition bräuchten.
Hopp!
Oh, oh!
Boah, zum Glück ist das Ding nicht durch die Laser durchgelaufen.
jetzt können wir dachte kann man das einfach vorbeilaufen
ja jetzt kann man glaube ich einfach vorbeilaufen oder man kann die
explosiven dinger ok max das war eine ganz das war eine echt blöde idee gerade
ich hätte einfach weitergehen sollen
Granaten!
Was ich nicht brauche aber gut
Granaten
Guck mal da oben gibt es Shotgun Shells
Wie komme ich da hin?
Zu spät
Oh
Äh
Oh oh oh oh
Aha
MonkaS
Jetzt gehen wir doch die Tür zu.
Aha.
Outplayed.
Oh.
Hab ich mich jetzt ausgesperrt?
Nee, ich glaub man kann das wieder aufmachen.
Oh shit.
Highly trained professional.
Ich glaub ich hab mich ausgesperrt.
Hahaha.
Das kann nicht sein, dass man sich hier aussperren kann und zurückkomme ich auch nicht mehr.
Na geil.
Okay, gut, dass ich gespeichert habe.
Ach hier habe ich gespeichert, nice.
Es ist nie passiert.
Das ist nie passiert, Leute!
Alter!
Okay, ich warte jetzt einfach, bis die Tür zugeht.
Eigentlich schon. Ja, ich bilde mir auch ein,
dass du normalerweise die Tür wieder aufmachen kannst.
Vielleicht, vielleicht haben sie das
in dem Mod irgendwie gebuggt.
Diablo 4, ich werds mir, ich weiß nicht, ich hab, ich hab kein Bock auf Diablo 4, ich war so enttäuscht von Diablo 3, auch wenn ich zwischenseitig mal wieder ein bisschen gespielt hab.
Vielleicht, also wenns mir langweilig ist, vielleicht.
So, jetzt müssen wir mal unsere Grenades benutzen.
Nice, oh, oh, schnell, schnell, schnell, schnell, schnell, schnell.
X
Den dürfen wir nicht kaputt machen
Okay, so ist gut
Und jetzt können wir den von hier kaputt schießen
Bäm
Gibt's hier noch irgendwas spannendes?
Spannendes
MP5 Munition, Shotgun Ammo
Also wie gesagt meiner persönlichen Meinung das beste Half-Life Level, das hier jetzt und das anschließende
Ach jetzt kommen die Soldaten
Die interessieren sich für den Scientist überhaupt nicht, die haben ja mein Head da oben raus klitschen sehen, da hat's gedacht Instant Bam, den müssen wir platt machen
Der wusste halt einfach, da hat das mit einem Highly Trained Professional zu tun und da kann man nichts anbrennen lassen.
Highly Trained Professional.
Oh, ups.
Ups.
Ich hab grad einfach den Westschlaflötzer gesplattert in der Tür.
Achtung
Oh jetzt muss man das sogar vorhalten
Das ist ja Next Level Shit
Man muss Schüsse vorhalten
Das bin ich an Half-Life überhaupt nicht gewöhnt
Kann man nicht einfach hier mit der Shotgun
Kann man nicht einfach hier mit der Shotgun?
Ah, ich will eine Granate werfen!
Okay, Headshots sind auch nicht mehr das, was sie mal waren.
Ich glaub, ich glaub, ich glaub, es ist alles dead.
So, erstmal looten kurz.
kurz
looten
und
BÄM
Hier ist wahrscheinlich gar nix
drin
Oh doch Shotgun
Die sind einfach nur zur Deckung
wahrscheinlich da
Aber das Half-Life, da weiß man das nie
Wo nicht vielleicht doch noch ein bisschen was drin ist
Guck mal hier, Health-Kit
Hier ist einfach ne
sinnlose Ecke
Siehste? Siehste?
Sag ich doch
Irgendwo ist immer was drin
Und...
Ah!
Der...
Und...
So, nach mir kommt da keiner mehr rein!
Wenn wir Glück haben, können wir da irgendeinen exploden von denen.
Hm.
Links oder rechts?
Das Game möchte, glaube ich, dass wir rechts gehen.
Eins, zwei, drei, vier, eins, zwei, drei, vier.
Oh, sind da oben Gegner.
Man kann das kletschen irgendwie, man kann glaube ich hier so...
Aber vorher, ich muss gucken, was in den Kisten drin ist.
Ah, ist in den Kisten.
Alter, Gorn ist echt dick geworden.
Wie viel Leben hier verteilt wird, so viel brauche ich gar nicht.
Guck mal, 100, 100.
Und wir spielen schon auch schwer.
Jetzt, ah, Game.
Wenn, also...
Jetzt kommt gleich so ein...
Jetzt kommt gleich so eine stationäre MG, wenn ich das richtig im Hinterkopf habe.
Ähm, da nehmen wir wirklich mal eine Granate.
Oh oh, oh oh, oh oh.
Highly trained professional.
Was bringt das denn? Das ist ein Schild.
Das ist ein Schild. Also du verlierst weniger Leben, wenn du noch Schild hast und manchmal gibt es so irgendwie elektrische Böden und Giftlachen und sowas, da wird auch zuerst die Schildenergie abgezogen, bevor man Leben verliert.
Das hat überhaupt nichts gebracht, dass ich hier jetzt lang bin, oder? Hier ist ja gar nichts.
Ich kann höchstens diese Dinger zerstören da unten. Einfacher von hier oben.
Oh oh, ganz blöde Idee, Max!
Oh shit!
Nice!
Five head time, sehr schlau gewesen.
Ähm...
Ich könnte auch einfach hier dran vorbeispringen, ohne dass ich was... genau.
Viel sinnvoller eigentlich.
Oh oh, jetzt...
Kriegen sie aufs Maul.
Granate!
Noch ne Granate, weg hier!
Oh oh, oh shit.
Muss erst mal kurz das Ding da hinten kaputt machen.
Und hier, dass nix mehr von hinten kommt.
Den hat's gesplattert von so einem Ding an der Decke, weißt?
Das waren bestimmt noch nicht alle.
Bam!
Doch, ich glaub das waren alle!
Die sind alle in diese Barnacles reingerannt.
Das waren definitiv keine Highly Trained Professionals.
Mir würde das natürlich nicht passieren sowas, klar.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Und die Waffen haben Rückstoß.
Was ist denn da los? Das ist mein Half-Lifer gar nicht gewöhnt, dass Waffen Rückstoß haben.
Da muss man ja wirklich mit den waffen muss man ja wirklich jetzt halbwegs normal schießen da kann man nicht mal dauerfeuer machen und hätte alles
Was ist das
Das wird so skillvoll
Ich deaktivieren
Falls sich noch jemand an Plank Mesa erinnern kann, das haben die fast eins zu eins hier
so nachgebaut.
Aber ich muss sagen, ohne Mist, mir liegt halt Half-Life 1 am Herzen auch original.
Also so geil Plank Mesa war und es ist sicherlich auch für neue Einsteiger das bessere Game,
ich spiele Half-Life 1 lieber.
Oh nein! Keine Ammo mehr!
Gibts aber ganz schön auf den Sack, lebt da noch was?
Ne, ich glaub alles dead, gell?
All dead!
Man sieht es Kids in Half-Life ja auch nicht an, ob die stabil sind oder nicht.
Ich glaube ohne Scheiße, ich glaube ich muss die nicht alle zerlegen.
Guck mal, wir haben immer genug Leben, wir haben eigentlich alles genug. Wir haben genug Muni, wir haben genug Leben, wir brauchen das eigentlich gar nicht.
Außer, dass es ein cooles Gefühl ist, die Kisten zu zersplattern.
Gibt's da eigentlich nix, warum man das so machen muss.
Wenn wir irgendwie knapp an Munition sind, können wir das immer noch machen.
machen
jetzt kommt glaube ich das was man nicht gewinnen kann gegen den heli
helikopter stelz
wo man einfach nur durch rennen muss
in der hoffnung nicht zu sterben
oder fliegen gerade 50 granaten
Ich hab keine mehr. Shit, ich hab keine Granate mehr.
Oh shit.
Mit Pega-Aim. Nice.
Ey, lasst mich doch mal in Ruhe nachladen.
Die machen Damage.
Nachladen, nachladen, nachladen, nachladen, nachladen, ja, ja, gut Gordon, so machst du es fein.
Das ist im Black Mesa übrigens ja auch alles ein bisschen größer.
Ich glaube man muss jetzt nicht einfach nur beeilen, dass man hier durchkommt.
Man kann, ich glaube wenn ich das richtig erinnere, man kann, ja das wollte ich euch jetzt nicht sagen, man kann glaube ich, alter lass mich doch mal raus hier.
Ah man kommt nicht mehr raus, ok.
Man kann glaube ich das Ding abschießen.
mit irgendwelchen Tricks. Ich glaube man kann den Heli abschießen, indem man
sich auf den Turm klitscht oder so.
Jetzt sind wieder mehr als genug Muni, mehr als genug Leben, mehr als genug Shield.
Explodiert zwar gerade alles, aber das soll uns mal alles nicht stören.
Jetzt kommen sie hier abgeseilt
Ja
Und
Zersplattern sich selbst
Als Kacknoobs sind
Oh oh oh oh
Shit Shit Shit
Geschafft.
Achtung.
Gucken, dass es nicht wieder so ne riesen Hitbox ist.
Kommt man da vorbei?
Boah, das wird fast in dem Game wieder...
in dem Game wieder, hier, das klappt doch wieder nicht.
Okay, oder doch?
Lüftungsschacht.
Gestälze.
Ich war damals von der,
von der Flashlight,
Physik, kann man das Physik nennen?
Voll beeindruckt, so das, wenn man den,
so in Gängen lang guckt, das ist dann so.
Ich mein, das ist halt absolut nicht so, wie sich eine... wie sich äh... so eine Lampe verhalten würde, ne?
Aber, war das... war das Pog?
Weil ich mein, das ist ja kein Laser, so nach dem Motto, ja da vorne wird's... ist was und in der Mitte ist nix, also nie... nie... nie im Leben wär halt eine Lampe, so.
Aber so ist das halt, wenn man so Games zum ersten Mal mit 13 spielt.
Und es ist halt auch so, also...
Ne, für damalige Zeit war das echt richtig Pog.
Auch das Flimmern der Lampe und so, die ist ja gar nicht durchgängig.
Es ist aber halt wirklich so, wenn ihr sowas zum ersten Mal spielt...
Das bleibt euch im Kopf, das ist dann quasi immer für euch Best Game Ever,
egal ob es in der heutigen Zeit noch irgendwie groß mithalten kann.
Geht's hier nicht weiter?
Hä?
Komm ich her, oder?
Ach!
Wait a minute, das ist da, wo ich runter gehüpft bin, oder?
Ich glaub, ich bin einfach nur zu pepega gewesen,
das zu checken.
Ja, Three Head.
Ich glaube, jetzt kommt demnächst so ziemlich der unbeliebteste Part von Half-Life 1, nämlich
das On-Rail-Level.
Aber vorher kommt noch...
Vorher kommt...
Ne, Plaspid oder wieder...
Ne, beim Plaspid kommt danach...
Ach, keine Ahnung mehr.
Aber ich glaube, jetzt kommt dem nix on Rail.
Und niemand...
Und niemand mochte on Rail.
Weil, wer mag schon die Bahn?
Zen!
Ich bin tatsächlich einer der wenigen, der Zen mochte.
Ich bin tatsächlich einer der wenigen, der Stan mochte, viele mochten es nicht, was ja auch dazu geführt hat, dass die Black Mesa Leute gesagt haben, sie überarbeiten Stan nochmal komplett, was sie auch wirklich gut gemacht haben, das muss man ja mal anerkennen.
Aber ich finde Xen in Black Mesa ist fast schon ein bisschen zu gestreckt, die zweite Hälfte.
Also nicht die zweite Hälfte vom Game, sondern die zweite Hälfte, die zweite Hälfte von, von Xen.
Okay, das hat sich ja überhaupt nicht gelohnt, dass ich das grad in die Luft gesprengt hab, aber...
Okay.
Oh! Äh, hey!
Ey, stopp! Stopp, stopp!
Okay, das war's.
Das war's.
Ich hab das ja schon gedrückt
Hab ichs kaputt gemacht?
Hab ichs irgendwie
hab ich es irgendwie kaputt gemacht durch meine hoch und runter fahren lassen?
ne
ne ne passt schon
ich hätt es einfach nur doppelt machen müssen
Was zum Teufel?
Hab ich das irgendwie kaputt gemacht gerade?
Das ist das nicht...
Ist das, ist das...
Broken?
Och ne, oder?
Highly trained professional
Der Fahrstuhl ist gerade durch den geschlossenen Schacht gefahren.
Ja, ich glaube, ich habe es irgendwie kaputt gemacht.
Kann ich vielleicht jetzt hier runter?
Ah, da ist der Fahrstuhl.
Okay.
Ich glaube, ich habe es irgendwie kaputt gemacht.
Fuck.
Ich glaube ich habe es irgendwie ich habe es irgendwie kaputt gemacht
Okay jetzt wird es natürlich ein bisschen kompliziert wie fixe ich das denn wieder muss ich mich durch muss ich mich durch klatschen
No clip
Nee, nee, nee. Ich hab ne Idee. Nee, nee, nee. Ich hab ne Idee, Leute. Ich hab ne Idee.
Pass mal auf. Pfeifert. Pfeifertime. Pfeifertime.
Fuck!
Hab ich noch ein Save davor?
Ähm...
Orzo Save Plast Pit, das klingt doch gut.
Ja, das ist ja quasi gleich hier am Eingang.
Oder, oder, ne ihr habt recht, Chat, Chat, viel besser.
Noclip.
Ne, ging das so?
Ne.
Blei, Noclip?
Nein, kein Clip!
SV
Sheets 1
Kein Clip
Jawoll
Exzellent
Hallo
wir haben es geprägt
noclip
wir waren nie bewusst dass das game so viele bugs hat es könnte aber auch am ort liegen
greifen die mich nicht an
doch machen sie ich finde cheaten zum progressen weil es kaputt ist es nichts
verwerflich ist was willst du sonst machen und jetzt fliegen wir gleich ein
stück jetzt katapultiert uns gleich über die halbe map
Passt auf!
Oh oh!
Bäm!
Oh oh oh!
Dafür braucht man...
Alter! Gordon!
Nicht nur Dick!
React!
XD!
Leitern klettern kann er nicht.
Rein da!
Jetzt...
Ah, ich erinnere mich.
wie viele haben davon hier noch jetzt aber alles jetzt die nächste frage wo
Wo ging's noch mal lang?
Ah, Half-Life-klassisches Röhren-Platforming.
Jetzt kommt doch Blast Pit, oder?
Wie kommt man da hinten dran?
Aha, hier drüber.
Wenn wir schnell genug...
Oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
So anscheinend nicht.
Komm, scheiß drauf, wir brauchen das gar nicht.
Bye bye.
C-U
Wie heißen die Dinger nochmal?
Chetke
Wisst ihr das, wie die Viecher nochmal heißen?
Die hatten...
Ich hab's vergessen.
Ähm ähm...
Bullsquid, oder?
Half-Life? Ja doch, ich glaub schon. Bullsquid, weiß ich nicht.
Oh!
Diese Viecher hier. Oh!
Achtung, Achtung.
Viel bessere Feuereffekte als im Original.
Das haben die definitiv überarbeitet.
Guck mal, er hier auch, er hier auch.
Ja, viel.
Also allein schon dieses
Zeichnen hier, das ist echt
sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr
gut gemacht.
Viel also allein schon dieser flair der da kommt wenn du das in die luft sprengst sah nicht so gut aus im original
Und ein nee nee nee hautei sind die kleinen
Hautei sind die ich meine ich meine die hier wie die heißen
Hautei sind die
Jetzt blättert
Bei mir ist es nicht mehr 15 Jahre her, aber bei mir ist es bestimmt auch
7 Jahre oder so her, als wir das Original gespielt haben, Black Mesa, ich weiß nicht
Klingeling, hast du Black Mesa gespielt?
Also, es ist auch Poggers Remake, aber es kommt halt nicht so sehr an das Feeling komplett vom Original ran.
Ich meine, zum Einstieg würde ich sagen, ist Black Mesa schon das angenehmere Game zu spielen.
Bullsquid, ja gut, da habe ich doch recht.
Es ist übrigens auch nicht 1 zu 1 das Original, es ist mit M-Mod.
M-Mod hat ein bisschen die Visuals verbessert, man hat ein paar zusätzliche Features,
wie beispielsweise jetzt hier so einen Silencer auf der MP5,
oder eine Sache, die ich ja persönlich sehr nice finde,
Ja, zum Beispiel man hat jetzt ne Charge auf der Crowbar
Was ihm nix macht
Man hat nen Secondary Fire und nen Tertiary Fire auf der Crowbar
Und n paar andere Überarbeitungen
Bis jetzt muss ich sagen, finde ichs fast...
Könnte man es fast...
Mehr empfehlen von jemandem der das Original spielen will als das Original selbst
Einfach, weil ein paar Sachen ein bisschen moderner sind.
Typisches CS-Kiddy dann.
Da hast du auf jeden Fall auf was zukunftsfähigeres gesetzt.
Der geht jetzt down.
Der wird immer gesplattert vor dem Fisch. Immer.
So, nur für den Fall der Fälle.
Das war jetzt eigentlich gar nicht mein Plan, aber gut.
So, es gibt zwei Varianten, wie man das Vieh hier machen kann.
Entweder...
Also die offizielle Variante ist folgendes.
Die offizielle Variante ist, man muss Krach machen, irgendwo anders und dann langlaufen.
Man kann aber auch, wenn man schnell ist, und ich glaube nicht, dass ich das hinkriege,
Man kann auch, wenn man schnell ist...
Hey! Ich hab's hingekriegt!
Nice!
Aber wenn man schnell ist, kommt man auch so durch.
Highly trained professional?
Haben sie doch am Anfang schon gesagt.
Wa-
Was spuckt hier auf mich?
Oh, da unten.
Ausgespuckt
Ach jetzt kommt diese Generator-Anmach-Org hier
Ich mag übrigens, als einer meiner Lieblings-Sounds aus Half-Life, dieses Nachladen von der Shotgun-Patrone, dieses hier, dieses...
Das hört sich so nach nem Schmatzer irgendwie...
da irgendwie. Übrigens angeblich soll das Game... Was für ein Knopf ist denn CS? Waffen
inspizieren? Angeblich soll der Mod auch Waffeninspection haben, dass man sich die Waffen angucken kann.
Vielleicht ist das der gleiche Hotkey wie ein CS?
Was ist ein CS? F?
Ne, F ist Flashlight.
Gäblich haben die auch Waffen-Inspection.
Spray-Logo, T.
Flashlight.
nicht. Aber ganz wichtig. Erstmal, erstmal nen Spray auf den Boden machen. Ich hab aber
Kein Spray-Logo drinnen.
Krasse Kletter-Animation, oder?
Hm. Wo geht's lang?
Hier geht's nicht lang.
Wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, basiert Half-Life 2 oder basierte Half-Life 2 während der Entwicklung haben die aufgesetzt auf...
Alter, was hält denn das Ding aus, man?
Auf die Quake-Engine?
Ich glaube auf die Quake-2-Engine.
Und das merkt man wohl auch, unter anderem daran, wie man Bunnyhoppt und sowas.
Das war jetzt nix.
Aber nachdem ich das eh nicht kann, ist das für mich irrelevant.
Ah, da war es eine modifizierte Quake 1 Engine.
Ja, kann auch sein.
Jetzt kommt das mit dem Ventilator genau mit dem Ventilatorstelz kommt jetzt Leute
es genau so klettert man eine Treppe äh eine Leiter so so und nicht anders genau
genau so klettert man wenn ihr nicht so klettert macht ihr irgendwas falsch
woaaah, bäh
ah, Gordon auf, beweg dich
ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein
Einfach ganzes Leben falsch gemacht, ja?
Ja gut, dass du es jetzt korrigieren kannst.
Oh, ich habe keine Muni mehr.
Leute, fällt mir gerade auf.
Ich sollte mal nicht so verschwenderisch umgehen,
ich habe kaum noch Munition.
Zurück, zurück zum Brecheisen.
Ganz wichtig, Splatter-Animationen.
Oder, wie nennt man das, Animationen?
Wow!
Nein, einfach Munition sparen.
Warum kann ich die Viecher nicht einfach so umhauen?
Ist doch eigentlich viel sinniger.
Wow.
Einfach so umhauen.
Kühlsystem aktiviert.
Jetzt müssen wir zurück zu diesem Tentakel-Ding.
Dann müssen wir nochmal run- Dann müssen wir nochmal runter.
Ja, wir haben es geschafft.
Dann müssen wir nochmal runter und danach müssen wir den Raketentriebwerks-Test machen.
Was ich für einen Schiss hatte, als ich klein war, hier bei diesem Tentakel-Raum.
Das muss man ihnen lassen, also Sound, oder was sagt ihr?
Ich meine, für die Möglichkeiten von 1998 ist das schon wirklich cool gemacht.
Also auch das vom Sound-Design her, das fühlt sich wirklich gefährlich an, so als willst du da nicht reingehen.
Und es sieht ja auch gefährlich aus.
So, jetzt machen wir mal das Offizielle, so wie man das lösen soll.
Oh oh, schlechte Idee, Max. Ganz, ganz schlechte Idee.
Oh man, ich will das, ich muss das besonders stylish machen.
So?
Alter! Ich will das Ding mit der Granate aufsprengen. So, Leute. Bäm.
Ich bin zu unfähig dafür. Nochmal. Granate.
Granate. Durch. Ja, das wollte ich die ganze Zeit machen.
Hat nicht so ganz funktioniert.
Übrigens, der Typ, der hier unten sitzt, hier unten sitzt gleich so ein...
Ach ne, den hatten wir oben schon.
Das ist der Wissenschaftler, dem wo ich oben...
Wobei, ist hier nicht auch noch einer? Ne.
Das ist der Wissenschaftler oben, den ich aus Versehen...
Oder was heißt aus Versehen?
Wo ich die Crowbar-Animation zeigen wollte.
Der kann eine Spritze geben und der heilt einen.
Es gibt viele so kleine Sachen in Half-Life, die man gar nicht weiß.
weiß also die man die an das game auch nicht sagt viele der wissenschaftler wenn man die
anquatscht und glaube ich unter 60 prozent leben hat dann heilen die eine geben die eine
Spritze zum, ja für ein bisschen Leben. Oh oh, schlecht.
Ah
I'm stuck
Oh, und auch dieses Blim Blim Blim Blim, wenn die Shotgun-Shells runterfallen, hört mal.
Der Sound war schon extrem porkel.
Klar, kannst du das nicht wirklich mit 2023 vergleichen.
Vergleich das mal mit...
Okay, vielleicht nicht mit Battlefield 2042.
Aber die Battlefield-Games hatten auch immer super Sound.
Sound und da sieht man schon da geht da geht schon einiges mehr als zu 1998 Zeiten, aber trotzdem
Für 1998 war das extrem Pog. Hast du schon Plague Master gespielt? Ja, wir haben sogar im Stream durchgespielt
Plague Master ist auch ein tolles, ein wirklich super, super, oh
Super Remake
Aber, ähm, ich finde die Xen-Levels, also die sind wirklich gut gemacht und man sieht, die haben da sehr viel Zeit, Energie und Gehirn reingesteckt.
Aber ich finde die Xen-Levels, die zweite Hälfte der Xen-Levels sind in Black Mesa einfach zu gestreckt.
Äh, wo ist der Fahrstuhl?
Fahrstuhl.
Bad Company 2 hat deiner Meinung nach beste Soundkulisse.
Ja, ja, finde ich auch.
Also gerade auf Wartapes.
Und wer sich jetzt fragt, was ich hier mache, das ist Absicht.
Weil, passt mal auf,
Normalerweise würde meine Adresse da drin stehen.
Und irgendwann fällt er auch runter.
Wahrscheinlich, weil ich nicht drinne bin, fällt er jetzt nicht runter.
Ich hoffe, ich hab nix gekletscht dadurch, dass ich jetzt einfach schon vorher rausgesprungen
bin.
Highly trained professional.
Moin.
Aua.
Aua
Kleinmeister, dankeschön für den Sub, hab ich gar nicht gesehen
Ah jetzt kommt dieses Ding, das haben sie glaube ich in Plank Mesa auch verbessert, das war jetzt ein bisschen nerviger Part
Wir sind mit diesen fahrenden
Dingern da
Wow, close, close
Ich glaube das war es, was man machen musste.
ja war es ja auch es ist ja auch unter unter strom ist ja auch kein turner
wer von euch ist ist 5 hat und weiß wo gordon freeman seinen abschluss gemacht hat an welcher
Uni? MIT, richtig. Wisst ihr, was das Spitzige ist? Wenn mich einer fragen würde, ja, kennst
du jemanden, der seinen Abschluss am MIT gemacht hat? Keine Ahnung. Mir würde nur Gordon Freeman
einfallen. Also ich kenne irgendeinen virtuellen Dude, aber von irgendwelchen echten Wissenschaftlern
habe ich keine ahnung davon den gibt es bestimmt auch einige bekannte welche die
großartige dinger schon geleistet haben die die abschlüsse am mrt gemacht habe ich habe keine ahnung davon
fällt euch jemand ein so spontan ohne wiki zu gucken vom mrt der nicht gon freeman ist
Er bleibt mäßig haben wir doch sogar zu ende gespielt im stream oder nicht oder doch
Auch ich glaube schon
Naja, euch fällt auch keiner an.
Habe ich nicht zu Ende gespielt?
Okay.
So, jetzt wird es ein bisschen schwierig, jetzt müssen wir hoch.
Jetzt, jetzt müssen wir hoch.
Ich glaube, da bleibt uns nichts anderes
übrig, wie die ein bisschen
dead-ge zu machen.
Shit, Alter. Konnte man die nicht einfach so killen? Also nicht killen, killen nicht, aber dass die alle mal runtergegangen sind.
Anscheinend nicht.
Oder musste man schleichen?
Ich glaub man musste schleichen
Jaja, gehst du weg, weg, weg, weg
Mocker es
Oh oh, oh oh
Oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
Ihr habt nichts gehört
Ihr könnt mich hier überhaupt nicht treffen, ihr seid da einfach viel zu verbuggt für
Easy
Ich glaube nicht, dass das der Intended Way ist.
Aber er funktioniert.
Ha! Outplayed.
Okay.
Wo kommt denn das Viech her? Das war doch am Anfang noch nicht da.
Ich habe keine Pistole.
das ist sehr
unpraktisch gerade
jetzt wird's gegrillt
Cookie, danke für den Zapf
in your face
jawoll, Rakete
M
jetzt schreckt
er das Sounddesign war schon richtig klasse bei Half-Life
nice
richtig nice
oh shit
Ich hab keine Pistolen Muni mehr und nix, das ist sehr unpraktisch nur mit der Shotgun.
Aber ich krieg glaub ich gleich den Revolver.
Und beim Revolver muss man ausbrennen, der Revolver hat angeblich noch...
Ah...
Ich hab nur noch 54 Leben, das ist blöd, die Leben zu verlieren.
Egal.
Guck mal, hier liegen Überreste vorne rum.
Ich glaub jetzt krieg ich gleich den Revolver, dann hab ich wieder ein bisschen Muni.
Und das Bein gebrochen, ja das juckt ihn doch nicht.
Wohow!
Blub, blub, blub!
Hoffentlich keine Headcrabs!
Doch, es gibt Waffeninspections!
Hat man doch grad gesehen!
Aber wie kann man...
Schade, dass man die anscheinend nicht von Hand aufrufen kann.
So, was hat...
Wir schwimmen hier erstmal raus.
Wir schwimmen erstmal raus, dann gucken wir uns den Revolver an.
Was die dem für neue Fähigkeiten gegeben haben.
Äh, hier schonmal nicht.
Äh, da.
Okay, also was kann der Revolver Neues?
Rechte Maustaste macht nix, mittlere Maustaste?
Sniper-Mode.
Ah!
I see.
360 No Scope
Oh ja, 360 Time
One on one auf Rust, jetzt kann uns eigentlich nichts mehr passieren
Nein
Ja, der sieht besser aus.
Au!
Ich muss aufpassen, ich habe kaum noch Leben.
Das ist die Original-Kampagne gemoddet.
Und ich finde es bis jetzt auch, ehrlich gesagt, besser fürs Jahr 2023 geeignet als das reine
Original Half-Life.
Erstens, es sieht ein bisschen besser aus, also sie haben beispielsweise die Feuereffekte
Und ein bisschen, ich würde auch sagen ein bisschen die Partikeleffekte und teilweise die Beleuchtung verbessert und, äh, nein, falsche Seite.
Und die Waffen ein bisschen verbessert, vor allem vorne weg.
Die Waffen sind jetzt fast alle Projektil, Projektil basiert.
Also in Half-Life war es ja immer so, du bist über einem Gegner, hast abgedrückt und hast Instant getroffen.
Wenn du jetzt hier mal guckst, das sind, wie du siehst, das sind Projektile, die fliegen.
Was ich eine sehr gute Idee finde, was auch Movement tatsächlich sinnvoll macht.
In Half-Life 1 musstest du normalerweise überhaupt nicht moven.
Ach hier geht's...
Woah, woah, close, close.
Ah, das war so ein Verbindungsstück zwischen den Tunnels, ja.
I get it.
Aber Michael, 50 Milliarden, ich kann es dir echt empfehlen.
Das ist ein Game, was jeder gespielt haben sollte, meiner Meinung nach.
Wow!
Meiner Meinung nach.
Chat, wie seht ihr das?
Au!
Warum habe ich jetzt so viel Leben verloren?
Es ist überhaupt nichts passiert
Solltest du erst das Original spielen oder direkt die Mod?
Also normalerweise würde ich sagen erst das Original
Einfach das was man gesehen hat, aber wenn du es nur einmal spielen willst, ja, dann kannst du es ruhig mit dem Mod spielen
Ich finde es eigentlich ziemlich, also es ist, es ist das Original mit ein paar
quality of life Sachen mit ein bisschen Optik verbessert. Beispielsweise im Original
konntest du mit der Brechstange nur so machen. So, und hier hast du einen sekundären Schlagmodus
und sogar noch einen Charge Modus, was ich wirklich eine sinnvolle Neuerung finde,
gerade zum Kisten zerstören. Und bei der Pistole kannst du einen Silencer drauf machen.
Es ist ziemlich alles im geist des originals gemacht also du könntest schon den mod spielen
mod ist übrigens kostenlos auf
steam
Half-Life 2 original oder moddet muss ich ehrlich sagen weiß ich nicht ich habe lange keine half-life 2
Keine half-life 2 mehr gespielt
Ich würde sagen leute was haltet ihr davon
Wollen wir demnächst noch mal ein richtig krass gemoddetes half-life 2 spielen ich habe lange keine half-life 2 mehr gespielt
Bestimmt sechs, sieben Jahre habe ich Half-Life 2 nicht mehr gespielt.
So.
Es gibt einen Trick.
Passt mal auf. Es gibt einen Trick.
Ich zeige euch den mal. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich den jetzt hinbekomme. Es gibt einen Trick.
Fast.
Ihr habt's...
Ihr habt's gesehen. Es geht ohne Tripmines. Wirklich?
Wie geht... Wie geht es ohne Tripmines?
Ohne Tripmines? Nee, oder?
Irgendwie stinkts nicht hier.
Also ich kenn nur das.
Ihr seht, ich bin nicht gut, was Half-Life-Glitches angeht.
Also man kann...
Jetzt bin ich stuck.
Nein.
Jetzt bin ich stuck. Nice. I'm stuck.
Also man kann das Level skippen.
Ich will euch das nur einmal zeigen und wir spielen es ja nochmal weiter.
Also man kann das Level irgendwie skippen.
Ich glaube man braucht einfach gutes Timing.
Ich glaube man braucht einfach...
Ich bin wieder stuck.
Aber ihr könnt euch ungefähr vorstellen, wie es funktioniert, wenn man jemand ist, der es kann.
Ich bin schon wieder gestuckt.
Meint ihr, dass es patched?
Ne, ne, ne, das ist nicht patched.
Das geht bestimmt immer noch.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es patched ist.
Fuck, Alter!
Okay, wir spielen das Level nochmal.
Aber theoretisch kann man das skippen.
Mach die Minen doch schräg dran.
Wow! Bonker!
Oh!
Ha! Hätte ich euch mal beide da durchlaufen lassen,
laufen lassen, anstatt's Money zu verschwenden.
Nicht genau vor dich, ja siehste ich hab die Half...
Ich hab die Half-Life Glitches einfach nicht drauf.
Wir können's... Wir können's nachher noch mal probieren.
Also das ist jetzt noch ein cooles Level und danach kommt, glaube ich, das meist gehasste Half-Life-Level, nämlich das, wo man Bahn fährt, was wahrscheinlich am Bahnfahren liegt.
Berechtigterweise.
Der meistgehasste Half-Life-Level, nämlich das wo man Bahn fährt, was wahrscheinlich am Bahnfahren liegt.
Direkt.
Ich bin verwirrt, wo geht's weiter?
Also hier schon mal nett.
Hier komm ich her.
Hier komm ich rein.
Ah, hier unten.
und
So muss das.
Wird eigentlich Granaten auf dem zweiten Slot haben.
Okay, die outplayen wir erstmal.
Okay, das war blöd. Ich dachte, da kommt jetzt irgendwas.
Jetzt aber! Kackviech. Sinnlose Munitionverschwendung.
On Rail ist man schneller durchgelaufen als das offizielle hin und her mit dem Zug, man
muss aber nur den Weg wissen, weil man den Weg weiß schon, On Rail ist auch nicht groß,
Es kommt einem nur am Anfang so, so verwirrend vor, ähm, eigentlich total blödsinnig.
Warum mache ich, warum mache ich die Tür zu?
Ich muss doch nachher wieder zurück.
Hallo.
Was ist da los?
Ah.
Ey!
Ich glaub das war totale Munitionsverschwendung, oder?
Das Feech wär da nie rausgekommen.
Yep.
Yep, Clock.
Das war einfach voll in den Kopf geschossen mit der Magnum.
Juckt ihr nicht, ist eben egal.
Interessiert ihr nicht.
Guter Helm.
Oh ich hab sechs Granaten, die sollte ich vielleicht mal benutzen.
Das ist das Beste gegen die Soldaten
Bäm!
Die erste Granate war schon mal komplett für
ne Arsch
Das ist auch was, was in dem Mod neu ist
Man muss Tapfire machen
Halbes Battlefield hier
Oah, jawoll.
Direkt.
Hast du irgendwas vergessen? Ey!
Mein Gott, was halten die aus?
Mit der Shotgun davorstehen und ins Gesicht ballern. Ja, easy. Kann man mal fünf Schuss aushalten.
Viel mehr kann hier nicht mehr sein.
Ja, boah, wie sich der jetzt zerlegt hat.
Huge.
Ich hoffe, das war's jetzt.
Gucken wir nochmal schnell,
ob jetzt alles down ist.
Die, die Explosivkisten lassen wir, weil wenn ich's richtig in Erinnerung habe, dann kommen hier gleich noch ein paar Viecher
Aus der, aus der anderen Richtung, wenn man fertig ist
X
Ja
Jugendfreie Inhalt.
Nice.
So jetzt sind wir auf der Seite.
Wo ging es jetzt lang?
Ah man muss den Fahrstuhl runterfahren, gell?
Ja, ja, ich erinnere mich. Fahrstuhl. Genau, Fahrstuhl. Fahrstuhl fahren.
Oh, oh, oh.
Outplayed!
Outmoved, outplayed.
Ich bilde mir auch ein, man soll hier eigentlich gar nicht lang, sondern man kommt eigentlich von der anderen Seite.
Ich glaube, man kommt eigentlich von der anderen Seite, wenn man den offiziellen Weg geht.
Stimmt, ne? War mir nämlich auch so, dass das irgendwie ein bisschen verkehrt ist, wo ich hier gerade rumstelze.
Nee?
Aber bei Black Mesa kommt man von der anderen Seite. Dann war es so.
Bei Black Mesa kommt man von der anderen Seite.
Nee, man... Okay, okay, doch, doch. Bei Black Mesa kommt man auf jeden Fall von der anderen Seite.
Das haben sie ein bisschen geändert.
Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ich glaube hier unten musste man hin um den Motor zu entstacken.
Ey, Alter, wieviel hältst du aus?
viel zu viel unsinnig damage genommen aber der motor entstanden
und jetzt einschalten
Die Gegner sind wie Oblivion Level? Ne oder? Ist das was? Also wenn überhaupt ist das neu in dem Mod. Das glaube ich nicht.
Das ist die Bait.
Ey wir haben es geschafft.
So jetzt müssen wir uns noch mit den restlichen Marines auseinandersetzen.
auseinandersetzen
Die wenn ich das richtig im kopf habe jetzt gleich den fahrstuhl runter gefahren kommen und in ihre eigene falle laufen pass mal auf
Da sind sie schon
Gebettet!
Aber ich bilde mir ein, da sind immer noch welche oben.
Ja, Achtung!
Warum halten die dudes so viel aus?
Hä?
Guck mal, habt ihr das gerade gesehen?
Der eine hat zwei Doppelshotgun-Shots ausgehalten.
Oh, hat's den schon zerlegt?
Nice!
Warum sind die Marines gegen dich? Du bist doch eigentlich ein normaler Mensch.
Ja, dazu müsste man die Half-Life-Story erklären.
Also, das ist folgendermaßen...
Es ist nicht so, dass es super kompliziert wäre oder so.
Also, man ist Wissenschaftler in einer geheimen...
Die Shotgun ist der RNG, ja, habe ich gemerkt.
Man ist Wissenschaftler in so einer geheimen Forschungsstation.
Und man führt da Experimente an.
Und die Experimente, die man durchführen kann,
die man durchführen kann,
Und man führt da Experimente durch und die Experimente gehen schief und jetzt hat man Aliens quasi so in die eigene Welt geholt und das Militär ist unterwegs
und versucht alle, die das gesehen haben, zu beseitigen, dass es halt nicht rauskommt, dass man da geheime Experimente durchgeführt hat.
Das ist so basically die Half-Life Story.
Also eins muss man sagen, der Mod übertreibt es mit Headcrabs.
So, ich glaub jetzt kann ich hier einschalten.
Oh, ich hab sehr wenig Leben.
Äh, was muss ich noch mal machen?
Ich glaube raus und irgendwas einschalten.
Ich muss erst wieder hoch und jetzt hier raus.
Genau, oh, oh, fuck, okay, das Fisch muss ich erstmal ablenken.
Falls ich es ablenken lässt.
Was ist das?
Kannst du dich mal verpissen vielleicht?
Ist das möglich, ja?
Achtung.
Vielleicht sollte ich einfach aus dem Fenster, vielleicht sollte ich einfach aus dem Fenster
springen.
Oh, blöde Idee.
Ich glaube, ich sollte besser gar nicht hier reinrennen.
Okay erstmal hier rein und jetzt und jetzt
Ja komm her komm her hier hier hier
Ich habe mehr leben ich habe erleben da ist
Ich muss nur den schalter drücken
Alter
Okay
Wait a minute, wo ist das Vieh hin?
Warum kommt das Vieh hin? Warum ist das Vieh hin?
Habe ich das Outmoved gerade vielleicht?
Oh, es ist gekletscht
Hier, hier bin ich
Auch, komm her
Ja, ja, hier
Uaah
Okay, auf. Komm her! Kackviech!
Deadge!
Ausschalten geht nicht mehr, okay.
Ausschalten, it's overrated, outdated, jebaited.
Wer musste schon ausschalten? Kann ich noch in die Kiste vielleicht gucken?
Handgranate? Handgranate.
Fog.
Nice.
Au.
Ah ja,
ich hab den Strom eingeschaltet.
Nicht so high IQ gewesen
von mir.
Gab's Medikits?
Wait a minute.
Es gab Medikits?
Wo gab es die Kids?
Wo denn?
Hab ich nicht gesehen. Hier?
Ach da!
Ah, nice.
Ne, die hab ich tatsächlich nicht gesehen.
So, jetzt kommt das wohl meist gehasste Level in ganz Half-Life.
Jetzt fahren wir nämlich eine Runde mit der Bahn, Monkadb.
Okay.
Jiiiiiii, Mon Castillo!
Ja, guck hier, wo wir drüber springen wollten.
Bäm! Kann man jetzt einfach durchfahren mit der Bahn.
Ich habe zu wenig Muni, gerade war es Pistolen, wobei habe ich gar nicht, eigentlich habe
hab ich mittlerweile genug
oh
ich hoffe wir müssen das garnicht
Ich fahre einfach mal durch.
Okay, gib Gas, gib Gas, gib Gas Freeman.
Jawoll.
Oh oh.
Oh.
Gerade auch überlebt.
So, jetzt kann man irgendwie tricksen.
Ich kenne mich hier leider in dem Level nicht so gut aus.
Also wenn man Ahnung von hat, ist man hier easy schnell durchgerannt, ohne mit der Bahn zu fahren.
Man kann die Hälfte vom Level skippen, wenn man nicht mit der Bahn fährt.
Und niemand mag dieses Level so wirklich.
Geht's hier lang?
Ah, Absteckgleis.
Einfach nichts, doch Magnum-Muni, die ich... Ah, drei. Drei Schuss noch.
Das ist glücklicherweise auch nicht so lang, wenn man weiß, wo es lang ist.
Woah! Woah, close!
Sonst wäre ich dead-ge gewesen.
Jetzt können wir mal was ausprobieren. Sniper-Mode?
Mal auf.
Bäm!
Reakt!
Kann man das kaputt machen?
Oh, oh!
Ist glaube ich kaputt.
So, jetzt kann man das umstellen, aber jetzt...
Man muss irgendwie da hoch, um das umzustellen.
Äh, ne, das will ich jetzt ja gar nicht.
Man muss irgendwie da hoch, damit man diesen Kran bewegen kann.
Aber wie kommt man da hin?
Boah man, ich mag das Level nicht.
Ist nicht, nicht dead?
Blind ge...
Mit Mine hochglitschen, ach nee
Moment, hier waren wir schon, oder?
oder?
Wait a minute!
Wir fahren gerade im Kreis!
Oh shit, ich noob.
Ich wusste eigentlich, dass es kommt.
Wir fahren im Kreis!
Okay, jetzt geht es hier lang. Ich bräuchte ein bisschen Leben.
Achtung, der wird wieder weggesniped.
Heh. Lul. Leben. Perfekt.
Perfekt
Hier unten irgendwie noch was drin
Sehr schön und ein bisschen munition besser
Langsam 1 2 3 4
Aha, exzellent.
Ähm...
Okay...
Ah, ey!
Gut, dass ich das Teil habe, das macht ordentlich Damage.
Ah, ein bisschen zu spät.
Noch mehr Grenades?
Ach, wir sind jetzt oben im Häuschen. Kran weg. Nice.
Wie ich hier keiner im Überblick habe. Ja, komm, spring mal an mir vorbei. Nice,
nice headcrab. Habt ihr in Half-Life auch immer so das Verlangen, jede Kiste zu...
Ja, hab ich.
Hab ich, hab ich.
So, jetzt müssen wir hier einmal...
Nein! Ey!
Alter, ich komm jetzt gebaited vor.
Warum bin ich schon zweimal
in das Elektro-Kabel reingefahren?
Oh, jetzt muss er hier rum.
Äh, jetzt...
Jetzt kommt das mit dem...
Mit den Türmen, dachte ich eigentlich.
Sack, Sackshot!
Ey!
Ja.
Ich fahr bestimmt nicht in der Mitte damit hoch.
Äh!
Ich hab's nicht verstanden.
Hä? Was hab ich denn jetzt gerade getroffen? Hier ist doch... HÄ? Was zum...
Der Typ ist... Der Typ ist tödlich hier!
Guck mal!
Okay...
Das erscheint mir ein kleiner Bug zu sein.
Das war's?
Wow wow wow wow wow
Highly trained professional
.
Aber hier einfach nur, just for fun.
Okay!
Wow!
Alter!
Meine Bahn fährt ohne mich weiter!
Komm mal, Fuß!
MonkaW! MonkaW! MonkaW!
Bin ich denn hier gerade stehen geblieben?
Rekt!
Einfach den Fuß weggeballert.
Easy!
Kann man das Ding eigentlich selbst bedienen?
Ich glaub das hab ich nie ausprobiert
Nee natürlich nicht
Macht auch keinen sinn weil ich glaube das ist die einzige stelle ich glaube ich glaube im tunnel
Ich glaube im tunnel später kommt es noch mal aber das war es ich glaube man kann das nie selbst verdienen
Was für eine range
Nee, nee, ich hab Schiss.
Okay.
Highly trained professional, Alter.
Okay, die können wir splattern mit ner Granate.
Alles down.
Sollte wieder mehr Spiele mit Quicksave geben.
Das stimmt wohl.
sind die sind die dumm warum rennen die an mir vorbei pp gas richtige pp gas oh da gehen
wir nicht lang doch wir gehen da lang da kommen wir nämlich direkt von oben raus was
viel besser ist kann man okay das probiere ich mal aus lass mich mal was
ausprobieren gerade passt mal auf kann man kann man kann man vorbei sneaken
Guck mal, die haben mich noch nicht gehört.
Ach, Knacke, ey!
Der Dude ist einfach selbst in die Granate gerannt gerade.
Kiste.
Oh, die sind nice die Dinger.
Schranke auf für die Bahn, exzellent, lass mal gucken ohne, dass ich Damage take.
Äh, irgendwas?
Okay.
Der Weg ist frei.
ist frei
also Leute ich glaub ganz ich bin ich bin super lahm
wie das Leute in
drei Stunden durchspielen beziehungsweise 26 Minuten Speedrun keine Ahnung
die Feuereffekte sind viel besser als im Original
da haben die sich viel Mühe gegeben
Richtige Boomer-Geschwindigkeit, ja?
Okay, okay.
Oh, ich hab ne Idee. Pass mal auf.
Oh ne, die sind gepanzert! Shit!
Das ist doch G-Bait, dass da so ein Ding steht.
Die wollen, dass man da dran springt
und feststellt,
man kann nix machen.
Okay, wie, wie, wie mach ich das am besten?
Der Dude ist dahinter, das weiß ich.
Ah, lol, rekt.
Blöde Idee, blöde Idee.
Sag mal kann man da nix reinschmeißen?
Okay
Alles jetzt funktioniert es bewegt sich noch es bewegt sich noch jetzt aber jetzt
Das ist ja dead.
Gebt mal ein bisschen...
Ein bisschen Armor oder sowas.
Gibt's nicht. Keine Armor. Overrated.
Was haben wir jetzt eigentlich genau gemacht hier?
Ah, wir haben die Schranke für die Bahn aufgemacht.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Ich kenn euch, ich kenn euch.
Ich wäre bestimmt gekellt, wenn ich da drauf stehen bleibe.
Und wenn ich mich richtig erinnern kann,
sind, glaube ich,
in dem Fahrstuhl
auch Gegner.
Oh, shit.
Super gemacht, nice Max, feilfettidee.
Ich muss doch irgendwie gehen, hier was dazwischen zu schmeißen oder?
Ey!
Was ist das?
Ah geht doch!
Geht doch!
Ah, geht doch!
Oh, und da hat's auch gleich noch die ganzen Marines zerfetzt.
Exzellent!
Äh, wo ist meine...
Wo ist meine Bahn? Ganz oben schon, oder?
ganz oben schon oder ohne mich
Oh nein, sieben Granaten! Ja, da kann man nix mal schiefgehen mit. Kann man einfach durchfahren?
Gib Gas, gib Gas! Freeman, Freeman! Jawoll, perfekt!
Weil Virtualbox ziemlich sackt mit 2D, 3D Beschleunigung auch im Desktop Betrieb.
Guckt es euch mal an, wollten sie mich gebaten.
Hat nicht funktioniert, ungebatable.
Achtung, Stelzmodus aktiviert.
Soll ich hier überhaupt lang?
Au!
Da ist er einfach, Matsch.
Ich glaube, gleich haben wir es geschafft.
Okay, ich fahr... Ey Leute, ich... Ich fahr einfach durch jetzt. Ist mir zu blöd.
Wir fahren einfach durch bis zum Schluss. Fertig.
Okay, nice. Ich glaube, wir haben es geschafft.
Fertig. Fertig on-railed.
Fertig on-railed.
Oh oh.
Shit!
Aua, warum ist das, wie das lebt noch, warum lebt das Viech noch?
eins eins gibt's noch
gut alter schwere geburt
So, kommt jetzt das mit der Rakete?
Oh, oh oh, Sniper-Modus!
Ey, die haben die AI definitiv verbessert!
Wird es Diablo 4 Crying Game? Ich weiß ja nicht, ob ich Bock auf das Game hab.
Die haben die AI definitiv verbessert hier.
Okay, ich muss mich beeilen.
What the fuck, Alter, wie soll das?
Okay, der ist dead.
Direkt, direkt dead.
Okay, wir müssen uns, wir müssen uns jetzt einfach nur beeilen.
Aufhören zu schießen, aufhören zu schießen.
Okay. Nice. Und jetzt Granate.
Rekt. Jawoll. Down.
Ich bin ziemlich low life. Die ganze Zeit. Muss man ja mal sagen.
Kommt nicht erster Boss, Veid?
Ähm...
Doch.
Ne.
Weiß nicht.
Achtung.
Alter, ich bin...
Ich bin ja unfähig.
Oh, Zähne.
Also ich bin ich bin ja unfähig hochzähne
Nice ein neuer feuer effekt
Nix da
Auch gut nice
Der Dialog war wichtig für die Story. Ich hab keine Ahnung, was die Typen erzählen.
Ist das, ist das dieses, ist das der Forget-
Ist das das Forget-About-Freeman?
Ne, das kommt später erst.
Ich werd, ich werd 360-Scoped-Sniped da oben gerade.
Ey, sind da mehrere, mehrere Scope Snipes, HD?
Okay, jetzt wird's schwierig mit 63 Leben nur der Fight.
Die AI ist wirklich viel besser als im Original.
Man kann es auch einfach alle headshotten, das geht auch.
Da braucht man gar nichts, dann sind sie einfach weg.
Fast schon Intervention-Camp, ja fast, ich erkenne gewisse Parallelen.
Hier gibt's gleich die Rakete.
Ja jetzt kommt was, was wir aus Black Mesa rausgestrichen haben.
Dieses, dieses blöde, dieses komische Kisten-Puzzle-Game und die Kistenphysik ist halt einfach zu gut
in dem Spiel.
Die Kästenphysik ist halt einfach superior.
Hahahaha, the fuck?
Ich mag gerade auf einmal 180 kmh schnell.
Also superior Kästenphysik.
So, ich glaube nämlich, dass man, wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe, man muss die
große Kiste reinpushen, die große Kiste reinpushen und dann die kleine Kiste reinpushen.
Ey, ich raste aus, ey, was ist das für ein scheiß Kistenphysikzeug, ey.
Kann man auch hier oben irgendwie einfach so drauf
Ach das geht auch Das wusste ich nicht, das ist mir komplett
neu dass das geht War mir gar nicht bekannt
Ich dachte immer man muss hier neben mit den Kisten irgendwie die austauschen
Das geht wahrscheinlich auch.
Oh hier ist der Kontrollraum für die Rakete.
SpaceX Control Center
oder Chainlore, ich bin so 3Header, dass ich das schon gar nicht mehr weiß.
Massive Raketen Start Physix
Ich fand es damals immer so doof, dass man nichts gesehen hat, richtig?
Ich meine, heute ist mir klar, warum die das gemacht haben.
Weil die Rakete halt einfach nur so wie eine Tür vorbeifährt, ohne dass man irgendwas überhaupt sehen würde gescheit.
Das hat schon seinen Grund, warum die das so versteckt haben, ja?
Wenn man das komplett gesehen hätte, hätte halt total billig und unbeeindruckend ausgesehen.
Aber ich hab mir damals immer gedacht, warum habt ihr denn hier nur so einen kleinen Schlitz reingemacht? Man sieht ja gar nichts.
Das macht den Black Mesa schon mehr her.
Den Black Mesa kannst du ja der kompletten Rakete zugucken beim Starten.
Und siehst hier dann sogar oben immer kleiner werden, bis man nix mehr sieht.
Jaja, ich versteh schon, warum es das storytechnisch gibt, aber ich fand's halt immer blöd.
Shit. Funktioniert wohl so nicht.
Okay, nice. Rakete ist weg.
Ach, man hätte auch hier einen MG gehabt gegen die.
Ne, das MG suckt.
Jetzt muss ich den Sniper snipen.
Counter snipen.
Intervention.
Okay, zum Counter snipen, ihr wisst ja.
Okay, jetzt kann es losgehen.
Down. Deckt.
180. Quickscope.
Ah, es gibt mehr Minen.
Ah, von denen wo ich kaum was benutzt habe bisher, aber kann man nicht genug von haben.
Es hat übrigens einen Grund warum ich, warum ich Duncan auf C liegen habe, normalerweise
bin ich eindeutig ein STRG-Croucher, ich habe es auf C liegen, weil C bei mir, weil STRG
mir noch Desktop switchen ist. Und wenn ich SDRG drücke beim Crouchen und die Maus bewege,
dann switcht auf einmal auf den zweiten Desktop. Deswegen hampel ich hier teilweise so mit C
und Crouch rum. Ah, jetzt kommt das. Ich weiß, ich weiß. Jetzt fliegen wir gleich durch die
die Wand.
Weeeey, bääh!
Wow.
Oh, ich glaub man muss abspringen vorher, kann das sein?
Okay, man muss vorher abspringen.
Eigentlich Billigbäumer musste nicht vorher abspringen.
Man ist dann runter ins Wasser gefallen und konnte weitermachen.
Dachte ich zumindest.
Aber anscheinend ist das falsch gedacht.
Es ist ja auch schon eine ganze Weile her,
wo ich das Original Half-Life gespielt habe.
Was ist ja anders als beim Original,
du hast einen Schalldämpfer auf der MP5.
Also du hast verschiedene, du hast neue Waffen, du hast neue Waffen-Modi, zum Beispiel ist
jetzt rechte, rechts, ähm, rechts-klick, also secondary Schussmodus für die Pistole, ist
ein genauer Modus und sowas und du kriegst mehr Waffen und sowas, ist auch egal.
Übrigens was ich richtig cool finde ist die Crowbar, die hat jetzt nicht nur dieses standardmäßige
Ding, die hat einen Sekundärmodus, Heavy Attack und einen Charge Attack.
Mega, mega.
Ich hab übrigens gar nicht ausprobiert, was die Shotgun hat, die hat keinen Secondary-Terziary-Modus.
Die Granate vielleicht?
Ah, man kann die werfen. Okay, das ist mir noch...
Äh, nope.
Ich sollte mal nicht so viel Munition verschwenden, um Zeug hier zu zeigen.
Hat die vielleicht einen anderen Modus noch?
Nee.
Ja, also, du hast ein paar grafische Verbesserungen, du hast leicht überarbeitete Level, du hast überarbeitete Gegner-KI.
Muss ich das mal durchlesen? Muss man bei Steam gucken? M-Mod?
Da gibt es eine ganze Liste, die haben einiges geändert, aber sie sagen ja selbst, sie wollen das quasi so im Geist des Originals erhalten.
Und das ist ihnen auch wirklich gut gelungen.
Es ist ja auch ein Half-Life 1 Mod.
Also es ist kein, wir bauen wie Black Mesa, wir bauen Half-Life 1 nach, es ist die Original-Kampagne mit Verbesserung.
Hast du dir wegen Half-Life auch bei COD immer Interagieren auf E gelegt? Ich habe immer Use auf E, sofern es möglich ist.
ESDF oder WASD? WASD. Eindeutig WASD.
Ah, war das jetzt Physikspielchen war das, oder?
Physikspielchen. Guck mal, den Mist haben sie in Half-Life 1 schon gemacht.
Okay, jetzt können wir den Zombie chargen.
Mit der Crowbar.
Bam!
Der ist auch gleich down.
Und danach, ganz wichtig, können wir ihn zersplattern.
Und den Typ hier, den können wir auch zersplattern.
Und den hier...
Oh...
Bäm!
Ah, fuck.
Auf den Index, Half-Life 1
war in Deutschland
nur krass zensiert zu haben.
Da gab es kein Blut und das hier waren
alles Roboter. Und die Wachmänner
und die Wachmänner haben sich
auf den Boden gesetzt.
Die Wachbänder haben sich auf den Boden gesetzt und mit dem Kopf geschüttelt, wenn sie keine HP mehr hatten.
Das war so die Hochzeit von komischem Zensurshit in Deutschland, was Games angeht.
Da gab es ganz viele Games, die es entweder in Deutschland nicht gab oder so komisch geschnitten waren und so.
Da waren wir berühmt berüchtigt für
Mal ganz blöd gefragt wo muss ich jetzt hin
Ich weiß es ich weiß easy ja fast man muss tauchtauch stelz machen
Und jetzt kommt gleich für mich persönlich das unangenehmste Half-Life Level, also es
wirklich nur für mich, alter Blutegel, für mich persönlich, weil ich hab's euch, ich
Ich hab's euch, glaube ich, als wir Black Mesa gespielt haben, habe ich euch, glaube ich, genau an der gleichen Stelle erzählt.
Passt mal auf, was jetzt kommt.
Jetzt kommt das Ding mit dem trüben Wasser und dem Fisch drinne.
Jetzt muss man da hochklettern und die Armbrust sich holen.
Ach ja, und der Boden ist rutschig.
Der Boden ist rutschig hier übrigens, by the way, wie man hier sieht.
Ja, und ich erzähl euch jetzt die gleiche Story einfach nochmal, die ich euch auch bei
Black Mesa erzählt hab.
Es gibt so eine Sache vor, der hab ich ein bisschen Schiss.
Und das ist, das ist tiefes, tiefes Wasser, wo ich nicht weiß, was drin ist, beziehungsweise
trübes tiefes Wasser.
Deswegen kann ich persönlich auch nicht in Badeseen schwimmen gehen.
Ich krieg das nicht auf die Reihe.
Schwimmbad und so, wenn man tauchen kann und dann mit der Brille unter Wasser alles sieht, gar kein Problem
Aufm Whiteboard erkennt man nicht irgendwelche Namen oder so
Ich kann, ich kann an keinem Badesee schwimmen
Also ich kann schon und ich hab auch schon, aber es erfordert immer
erfordert wirklich Überwindung, hab ich auch kein Bock
Schwimmbad kein Ding, klares Wasser auch kein Ding, aber tiefes, trübes Wasser, wo ich nicht weiß, was drinnen ist, beziehungsweise nicht reingucken kann, das ist ein leichter MonkaS-Moment für mich.
Und jetzt wird's noch mehr MonkaS.
Jetzt fällt man hier rein und muss die Typen irgendwie quickscopen, die komplett eskalieren, Alter!
Guckt euch das mal an!
...
Sag mal, kannst du mal sterben? Please!
Ah! Ah! Da ist noch einer!
Ich muss weg! Ich muss weg!
Ich bin raus hier!
...
Hier sind wir wieder!
Oh ne, ich muss ja wieder ins Wasser!
Shit!
Man kann das Fisch übrigens auch so killen, man kann es sogar mit der Pistole, ähm, im Käfig ist sicher, im Käfig hat man aber nicht unendlich Luft, pass mal auf, wir pisteln den Fisch jetzt einfach, wir pisteln den Fisch, weil hier kommt er nicht rein.
Guck, Kacknoob ist das!
Lol, down, wrecked!
Der Kackboden, genau!
So, einmal aufmachen, weil das können wir nicht machen, wenn solange der Fisch hier drin rumschwimmt, kannst du es vergessen.
Auch gleich am Absaufen.
Armbrust nachladen.
War die Idee von dem Level, dass die normalen Waffen nicht funktionieren? Es funktioniert auch nur die Pistole und die Armbrust.
Sind die einzigen die funktionieren.
Pistole in der Armbrust
Das geht nicht
Ich glaube Granaten kann man noch werfen unter Wasser
Wir könnten noch einfach
Nice, sehr fairer Spawn
Okay. Gut.
Ist hier was drinne?
Irgendwas spannendes?
Oh, jetzt kommt schon wieder so ein Wasserding mit Fischen drinne.
Aber ich glaube in das hier muss man nicht.
Muss man nicht rein.
Aber es ist rutschig.
Das geht kaputt.
Ja.
Es ist Rutsche das Geht Kaputt Ja
Ich habe so wenig Leben das wird das wird Knapp
Okay ich Glaube man Muss IrGendwie Hier Durch Jop da ist
Und Jetzt Bräuchte Ich Ein, Bisschen Leben
Äh, ja?
Oh!
Geckt.
Ja, so ein bisschen, so ein bisschen...
Woah!
Okay, dead.
So ein bisschen leben wär schon ganz nice.
Ich würde es unglaublich gerne spielen, aber ich habe keinen Bock, mir für ein Game eine VR-Brille zu kaufen.
Dampfer.
Gibt's denn noch irgendwas anderes?
Jetzt mal ne Frage an euch, die vielleicht ne VR-Brille haben.
Wenn man sich nen VR-Headset kauft
und sich das nicht nur für ein Game kaufen will,
ähm, was gibt es noch...
Oh, shit.
Hallo, please.
Was gibt's noch für gut...
Oh, come on.
Was gibt's noch für gute VR-Games, die sich lohnen?
Dass der Chat jetzt gleich wieder mit VR-Porn kommt, war mir ja schon fast klar.
ich hätte kaum mal danach fragen müssen. Superhot, das kenne ich sogar. Das ist dieser
Zeitlupe, Zeitlupe Shooter, der irgendwie so nur drei Farben hat. Ich sollte nicht Spiel
und Chat lesen.
Beat Saber.
Ja, den hab ich genug.
Horizon Call of the Mountain Half-Life Alex
Beat Saber, okay.
Okay, wenn man auf Flugsimulator spielt, dann versteh ich's.
Die Dinger halten eindeutig zu viel aus. Die haben im Original nie und nimmer drei Pfeile ausgehalten.
Was beats selber mit dem neuen Songpack?
Ach Queens Songpack. Queen oder Queens Songpack?
Queens Songpack klingt so nach Ayaya Anime Musik.
So, so Richtung, so Richtung äh...
Ayaya! Ayaya!
Ach, Queen! Ja, Queen kenne ich.
Dachte...
Das war die Frage.
Queens oder Queen?
Boneworks. Was ist Boneworks für ein Spiel?
Sagt mir gar nix
Dieses game hat eindeutig zu viele headcrabs in jeder ecke
Was ist boneworks für ein spiel hat bestimmt nicht mit nix mit jeb clock zu tun
Portal oder half life okay ja da stelle ich mir ganz cool vor
Stattdessen ist es besser als nackt zu gehen in diesem Ort.
Es gibt Löcher da drinnen und du musst schnell sein.
Es könnte deinen Schuhkopf in ein paar Momenten zerstören.
Wenn du auf die Lamda-Komplexe gehst, dann willst du dich in die älteren industriellen Orte halten,
wo das Sicherheitssystem voller Löcher ist.
Es ist Worte von mir, die ich dir verraten werde.
Und die machen keine Speedrun-Sachen.
Ich bin lahm.
Nee, dreieinhalb nicht. Ich hab bestimmt, ich hab locker eine halbe Stunde geschwätzt am Anfang.
Alter, was?!
Wollen die mich rollen?
Ja, please, geh da rein.
Dafür, dafür ist 25 Minuten Speedrun, aber irgendwie langsam, dachte das geht wesentlich
schneller.
Was?
Wirklich?
Fuck.
Du meinst mit rumgekletscht, direkt zum Boss oder sowas vielleicht, ja.
Ist das, bin ich einfach nur zu dumm, oder, oder hittet der Bogen nicht richtig?
Bei Portal sind es 8 Minuten.
Ja gut, Portal kannst du aber auch extrem rumklitschen, so mit ähm, kom-komplett-komplett irgendwie 20 Level skippen und sowas.
Oh hi, moin.
Moin.
Also ich würde sagen, wir spielen bis zur Hälfte des Games und dann gucken wir uns noch einen Half-Life Speedrun an.
Es sei denn, es ist euch zu viel Spoiler, bevor wir weitermachen.
Aber ich glaube, die meisten Leute haben mich schon mal irgendwann Half-Life gespielt.
Da könnt ihr mal vergleichen, das nächste Mal auch, mein Rumgehoppe versus den Speedrun-Dude.
Freeman?
Ja, der Typ ist gleich dead.
Ja, nice.
Jetzt kommt Assassin.
Assassin-Stills.
Ich weiß nicht, wie verbessert die sind, aber früher, also man konnte die relativ easy
trinken mit diesen...
Ja, okay, das funktioniert noch, nice.
Oh, die sind ja komplett unsichtbar.
Waren die das schon immer?
Ich camp einfach mit dem Granatwerfer in der Ecke.
Easy.
War's das?
Oh.
Was war das?
Noob-Tube! Wegge-Noob-Tubed, ja.
Ich glaub, das war's.
Ja.
Waren das nur drei?
Ich glaub, in Black Mesa haben sie hier sechs Stück hingestellt.
Jetzt müssen wir gar keine Munition mehr sammeln, weil, Achtung, Achtung, kein Spoiler,
aber gleich passiert was, was ich so auch noch in keinem Game vor Half-Life gesehen
habe.
Was mich sehr überrascht hat damals, wenn man jetzt hier reingeht, passiert nämlich
Man wird gefangen genommen!
Und natürlich nicht umgebracht, sondern in die Schrottpresse geworfen, obviously, was auch sonst?
Schrottpressen-Champ.
Und es liegt auch praktischerweise eine Crowbar dort.
So ging das hier.
So.
Au.
So, ich würde sagen wir gucken uns jetzt noch den Speedrun an, weil das ist ein super Einstieg
fürs nächste Mal.
Das ist genau die Hälfte des Games
Und wir haben alle Waffen verloren, es geht quasi so ein bisschen wieder, naja von vorne los kann man nicht sagen, aber es
Ist so ein Zwischenstopp. Es geht jetzt auch deutlich schneller gleich
Mit neuen Waffen und allem. Also das Game dreht ab jetzt eigentlich noch mal richtig auf
Ja, Brecheisen lohnt sich immer dabei zu haben, wie man hier sieht.
So, erstmal schön alles zerlegt.
Nice, ihr seid aber stehen geblieben.
Ich bin nie aufgefallen, dass da oben auch wirklich Dampf rauskommt und sowas.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das im Original auch so war oder ob ich mir das Level nie in Ruhe
angeguckt habe.
ASMR-Sounds, Mensch Zendrix heute will er es aber wissen, Dankeschön, weitere 5 giftet
Subs.
Wer hat wieder gedodget?
Okay, safe, also haben wir genau die Hälfte durch.
Ich würde sagen, wir gucken uns jetzt noch schnell den Speedrun an, der geht zackig,
25 Minuten.
Der aktuelle Half-Life Weltrekord Speedrun.
Weltrekord, Half-Life 80%, Scriptless. Scriptless ist wahrscheinlich so das Gegenstück zu, also
kein TAS oder sowas. Wobei Scriptless ist wahrscheinlich, Scripts benutzen die bestimmten
Half-Life zum optimierten Bunny-Hoppen oder sowas. Also, auf vier Monaten gab es den neuen
Weltrekord in Half-Life. Okay.
Scriptless.
Okay, zeigt mal her.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt. Jetzt könnt ihr meinen Rumgeeier mal
vergleichen mit einem, der das Game komplett gemeistert hat.
Lautstärke ist... ist okay oder soll ich die ticken lauter machen?
Alter, guck mal wie schnell er schon unterwegs ist!
Guck euch das mal an!
Ich... ich hab... ich hab bis hierhin irgendwie schon mal 5 Minuten gebraucht!
Ich mach ihn ticken lauter.
Das war ich nicht, das war ich nicht, das war bei dem im Stream.
Was geht bei dem ab?
Hat der den Sound von den Wachen irgendwie durch Keck W ersetzt oder war das zufällig
einfach im stream warum hat er gerade puls von 100 schon
Boah!
Alter, was für Chumps, man!
What the hell?
Das kenne ich, dass man die NPCs schieben muss.
Dass es schneller geht.
Alter!
krasser tut
Ich glaube das einzige was in diesem run irgendwie halbwegs normales ist der anfang
Wir erzählen ihm übrigens gerade, dass Gordon ein highly trained professional ist.
Marvellous!
You know all of this, he is a highly trained professional.
Er hat ein RGB Mikro, ja.
Mir war nicht bekannt, dass es RGB Mikrofone gibt.
Allerdings wundert es mich auch nicht, es gibt alles in RGB mittlerweile.
Oh, what? Ey, der ist so schnell, dass das Game sogar laggt beim Nachladen. Ich mach
mal kurz zwei, drei Sekunden Skip vor, weil hier passiert nichts, das ist das ganz normale...
ist das ganz normale wie bei mir auch nur nur dass er halt schneller ist
Was ist das?
Oh
W-W-W-W-
W-W-
Was?
Was, was passiert überhaupt?
Warst du damals auch so? Klar, ich hatte damals den Weltrekord, 1997.
Nur da gab's noch keine Weltrekordliste, deswegen weiß das niemand.
Ha ha ha!
Da kann man hoch?
das ist mir jetzt neu
ok keine ahnung
mir fehlen gerade die worte irgendwas zu zu
Das kann man hier nicht verarbeiten alles gerade auf einmal
Okay, das gibt das gibt auf jeden fall auch jetzt
Dieses ganze wir schalten den reaktor ein und sowas
Okay, der fährt auch gar keine Bahn, weil einfach Bunnyhoppen schneller ist.
So krass.
Ah ja, okay, alles klar, wie auch immer man da hochkommt so.
Aber wahrscheinlich Half-Life...
Half-Life-Physics?
Aber er ist nicht zufrieden damit.
Nun, es ist immer noch ein sehr schönes Stück.
Sehr schön.
Ich muss es irgendwie zerstören.
Und mega Pfoff, oder?
Poff ist so groß, dass der Arm und die Shotgun überhaupt nicht mehr mitkommt.
What?
Das geht, ohne dass man in der Mitte durchgeht?
Ich dachte, das Game muss in der Mitte durch zum Laden.
Ach nee, das muss nur das mit den Tentakel laden. Das restliche Level ist drumherum.
Wie, was meint ihr, wie viel Stunden Half-Life der hat?
Was war das?
Der hat bestimmt 3-4.000 Stunden Half-Life oder so.
Oder noch mehr, ich kann es schlecht einschätzen.
Okay, Kistenphysics.
Was, try? Ja, genau.
What the fuck, Alter.
Monkastier?
Ja, aber im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes Monkastier.
Kastir
Alle leute ich bin ich bin komplett sprachlos wir haben es ja auch eben gespielt
Der kerl ist bald in acht minuten so weit wie ich in dreieinhalb stunden
Okay, nicht ganz wir haben es ja bis zum gefangen nehmen gespielt aber trotzdem
der ich mal zehn minuten rum
Der ist auch gar nicht durch die Kühlkammer in Black Mesa und sowas, das kann man wahrscheinlich
alles skippen, wenn man weiß, wie man irgendwo durchklippt.
Und vier leben.
Äh, okay.
Warum leben die zwei NPCs wieder?
Ist das intended oder ist das... und ey ich blick nicht mehr durch, das passiert mir einfach zu viel gleichzeitig.
Ich geh mal davon aus, dass er auch einiges vom Game skippt oder schon geskippt hat.
Okay, da hat irgendwelche Custom-Sounds.
Okay.
What, what?
Hä?
Guck mal, das Game kommt bei ihm überhaupt nicht nach mit Laden von Umgebung und Text.
Okay.
Jetzt könnt ihr euch an...
Okay, das ist das, was ich vorhin probiert habe, sogar nur mit Minen uns nicht hingekriegt
habe.
Und übrigens, das ist das Level mit dem Zug, wo man den Zug gar nicht braucht.
Wenn man weiß, wo man hin muss und Planen vom Game hat und 4.000 Stunden Half-Life.
Obviously, klar.
Leute, ich muss mal kurz Pause machen, das geht mir zu schnell.
Alter, was ein heftiger Shit.
Ich hab ja schon ein paar Half-Life 1 und Half-Life 2 Speedruns gesehen.
Half-Life 1 Speedrun, muss ich sagen, ist auch schon eine ganze Weile her.
Die waren auch schon movementmäßig und sowas und und und und und abkürzungsmäßig extrem krass, aber das ist ja nahezu
Aus seiner Sicht ist es wahrscheinlich noch lange davon entfernt, dass es
Perfektes movement ist, aber das ist so geil, der drift irgendwie so das kleine Fenster
mit mit
1400 km h
Nach 300 meter sprung kommt er genau ins fenster rein und von da dann auf die leiter und alter
Das ist der Weltrekord-Run, ja.
Das ist wirklich extrem heftig.
Da fehlen mir wirklich die Worte, Leute.
Also wenn es euch gefällt,
ihr könnt ihn ja folgen.
TwitchTV
KanganaTV
Ich weiß nicht, wie oft er on ist.
Ich hab noch nie bei ihm Half-Life Runs geguckt.
Wir haben das hier über die
speedrun.com Weltrekord-Liste gefunden.
Krasser Scheiß, auf jeden Fall. So, jetzt hab ich Zeit gehabt durchzuatmen, jetzt kann ich weitermachen.
Der ist sehr oft am Abend online, okay, gut zu wissen.
Guck ich mal vorbei, aber das ist echt hart. Also, krass, krasser Scheiß.
Ich geh den jetzt mal kurz subscriben.
Auf dem zweiten Bildschirm.
Ich kann seinen Namen nicht schreiben.
Kann?
AngarnTV
TV
Also follown, nicht subscriben
Wenn ich Primes Up hab, kriegt er auch gleich Primes Up
Ey, hab ich nicht
Jesus
Das ist by the way das Level
Wo ich irgendwie 20 Minuten oder 30 Minuten gebraucht hab
Für das ganze Level
Aber ich hab ja auch den Noob-Modus gemacht und bin da mit der Bahn rumgefahren.
Ihr erkennt es vielleicht wieder, ist noch nicht lange her, vor einer Stunde ungefähr oder so.
Sind wir hier selbst durchgelaufen.
Wobei laufen kann man das bei ihm ja nicht nennen.
Durch, durch, durchgehavert.
Und alles mit sieben Leben.
What the f...
Was zum...
Das geht?
W-Wait a minute!
Man kann die Rakete von außen durchdrücken!
Gottes Appel, danke für den Sub.
Man kann den Raketenknopf von außen drücken!
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass Half-Life so
verbuggt ist.
War mir gar nicht so klar.
Ja klar geht das, ihr wusstet das natürlich schon immer.
Und euch war das quasi
beim ersten Playthrough schon klar,
Und klar Chat, alles klar.
Äh, warum genau ballert er da jetzt rum? Hat das irgendeinen Sinn oder ist das einfach nur Zeitvertreib?
Das ist Zeitvertreib, oder?
Ach, Timing, dass er weiß, wann was ist, oder?
Zählt der Schüsse, oder was macht er?
Ist das in Deutsch, auch keine Ahnung.
Oh, not too bad.
Ja, das Level haben wir eben noch gespielt vor einer halben Stunde.
Du softlockst, wenn du die Tür zu schnell öffnest, deswegen schießt er.
Ach so!
Ja, man sieht ja schon, dass das Game teilweise Probleme hat mit Nachladen und wenn es dann
irgendwelche Dinger fürs nächste Level nicht richtig hat oder was auch immer, wie man sich
da softlockt.
Ähm, äh, okay.
Oh, oh, okay, alles klar.
Mhm.
Oh, okay. Alles klar.
Kein Ding. Easy.
Hab ich vorhin auch so gemacht.
Guck mal, jetzt ist er quasi gleich da, wo ich bin nach dreieinhalb Stunden.
13 Minuten 47.
Okay, er hat noch ein paar Sachen geskippt, aber das macht's trotzdem nicht fett.
What the...
Okay.
Warum geht das da auf? Ich denk, man muss oben den Hebel ziehen.
Halt still man, das ist eine...
...seriöse Webseite.
Ja.
Hat er...
Was sind das für Einspieler, ey?
Er hat das Rad gedreht.
Ach, von hinten durch den...
Der ist da hochgesprungen mit der Granate...
...hat durch die...
...quasi durch die Wand...
...den Hebel gezogen...
...und ist dann runter.
Ah.
So, jetzt ist er exakt da wo ich bin nach dreieinhalb Stunden.
Nice.
14 Minuten 52.
Easy.
Kann man dazu nur sagen.
Easy as fuck.
Easy clap.
So.
Ich meine, bei dir sah das fast genau so aus, okay, passt auf, passt auf, man wird das sehen,
ich bin der nächste Half-Life-Speedrunner.
Oh
Ja ich finde es hat gewisse ähnlichkeiten ja es geht auch die tür zu
habe ich habe ich mich jetzt habe ich mich jetzt ausgesperrt ich glaube man kann das
wieder aufmachen also ich würde sagen das skill level ist schon ähnlich oder
ich habe mich ausgesperrt
Ja, ähnliches, ähnliches Skilllevel, würde ich sagen.
Oh, den Part müssen wir das nächste Mal noch spielen.
Allerdings, ihr müsst euch keine Gedanken machen, dass man zu viel sieht, falls ihr
das Camp noch nicht kennt.
Man erkennt ja eh nur die Hälfte.
Das ist so krass!
Das bei dem Speed auch noch zu treffen!
Ok ich glaub...
Hat...hat der grade...
Ich glaub...
gerade irgendwie das halbe Level geskippt oder kommt das mit den, mit den
Fleecebandern gleich noch?
Ne, das mit den Fleecebandern kommt jetzt noch. Okay, okay, also spielt das Game wirklich
durch, also kann man sagen, klar, ach da kann man drüber, okay, nur halt einfach
schnell. Es gibt zwar ein paar Sachen, aber es ist im Prinzip immer noch so, so
es ist immer noch Half-Life vom Ablauf der Level her.
What the fuck?
Wait a minute!
Man kann durchglitschen durch die Laser, wenn man's saved?
Das ist mir auch neu.
Wie er 145 Puls hatte...
...hat gerade...
...150.
Warum hat der 155 Puls? Da sagt mir einer Gaming ist kein kein Sport hier
Warum geht das Tor auf?
Normalerweise muss man da von der anderen Seite rein.
Knopf durch die Wand gedrückt.
Mir war gar nicht bewusst, wie viele Knöpfe man nervhaft durch die Wand drücken kann.
Was bin ich sehend!
Okay, die Waffe ist nice für Helis und sowas.
Wobei ich keine Ahnung habe, ob er auch nur einen Heli killen wird.
Okay, um hier durchzukommen, braucht man anscheinend wirklich noch so einen Wissenschaftler.
Ich hätte gedacht, der kann sich bestimmt da irgendwie durchkletschen jetzt.
Diese Sounds...
Moment, Moment, Moment Leute, jetzt muss ich mal kurz zurückspulen.
Was?
Also normalerweise muss man hier den Heli killen, dann durch den Damm schwimmen, unten drunter
durch und dann Richtung Lambda-Komplex hinter...
Krasser Kram, Alter, what the fuck, 170er Puls, das hatte ich heute Morgen beim Berghochlaufen.
Wenn überhaupt!
Let's fucking go!
Alles klar!
173!
Sicher, dass das ein Pulszähler ist und nicht einfach nur ein Counter?
Der ist Freak, ja danke für den Sub.
Ey, war das intentional, dass der Headcrab ausgewichen ist, dass der jetzt genau wusste,
dass sie in dem Moment springt?
Ah ok, jetzt wird mal ein paar Sachen wenigstens out of bounds geskippt.
Hätte ich eigentlich gedacht, kommt früher schon.
Aber da hat das Spiel ja fast, in der Anführung, fast normal gespielt bis jetzt.
Fast.
Also, vom Ablauf her.
Wird es am 5. einen Apple-Stream geben?
Ja, vielleicht mache ich das wieder. Die bannen ja anscheinend niemanden mehr oder die striken ja...
Wait a minute!
Apple hat ja...
hat mich ja mal gestrikt auf Twitch, weil ich eine ihrer Konferenzen gebracht habe, aber anscheinend geht das mittlerweile. Der Strike ist übrigens auch wieder weg.
Das ist ja auch geil, gut, ich dachte mir schon, dass man hier einfacher durchkommt
als wie ich, Casual Noob da immer außen rum, links rum, außen hoch, aber dass man da einfach
so drüberjumpen kann, hätte ich auch nicht gedacht.
Und mir war gar nicht klar, wie verbugged Half-Life ist, ich dachte das Game ist eigentlich
recht, recht gut, programmiert so und hat wenig Bugs, aber ist es ja auch, es fällt
einem im normalen spielen ja auch nicht viel auf
Okay alles klar
Halbe level geskippt
Half-Life ist nicht von Dice
Dann hätten wir mehr Bugs
Und andere probleme eine runde out of bounds auf dem geländer rum klettern okay
Gleich kommt ein toller Bug, den kenne ich, das ist der Unendlich Leben Bug, der jetzt gleich kommt, gell? Oder der jetzt kommt.
Ja, den kenne ich. Da kann man sich in die Tür klitschen und dann
overflowt irgendwie der Health-Counter und man hat quasi nahezu unendlich Leben bis zum Ende des Games.
Ja, den kenne ich, den kenne ich schon noch aus alten Half-Life-Runs.
Und er geht, glaube ich, auch nur in der ganz alten Version. Ich glaube auf der...
Ich genieße Farts im echten Leben.
Da seht ihr ungefähr, wir haben noch, also, dort wo ich aufgehört habe heute zu spielen haben wir noch ungefähr eine Viertelstunde vor uns, da sind wir durch.
Come on.
What the fuck?
Easy.
Easy, easy. Komplett easy. Easy Clap.
Das war übrigens der zweite Raum, wo die Assassins normalerweise sind.
Den Raum fand ich gar nicht so einfach, muss ich sagen, auf schwer.
schwer. Schön in den Fuß geschossen. Wie er halt weiß, wo die spawnen. Also ich denk
mal, das ist alles predicted, wo da welche Granate hingeht und wo welcher Gegner spawnt
und sowas. Und er killt halt auch nur das, was er killen muss, dass irgendwas getriggert
wird. Ich frag mich jetzt aber wirklich, wie will er in vier Minuten durch Xen, Xen, wie
Wenn man das ausspricht durch sein. Wahrscheinlich fliegt er da quer durch die Levels
Weil die Zen-Levels sind ja relativ offen. Wenn man da ordentlich Speed hat, kann man bestimmt die Hälfte des Levels skippen
Über nicht ganz intendet Wege
Normalerweise muss man da diese Teleport-Spielchen machen
What is happening?
ich habe keine worte mehr fällt mir fällt da gerade nichts zu ein
Ich habe wieder Ghost gespielt. Wie? Ich habe so lange gewartet.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Es ist 100 Prozent unschriftlich.
Man kann in den Teleporter rein, ohne den Fight zu machen.
Ach, das wurde auch gepatcht, okay.
Das geht wahrscheinlich auch nur in der...
Guck mal, man kann in den Teleporter rein, der ist auch gar nicht da.
Übrigens, das finde ich eines der coolsten Momente in Opposing Force.
Falls mal einer von euch Opposing Force gespielt hat.
Ähm, da kommt man kurz nach Gordon Freeman in diesen Raum rein und sieht ihn in den Teleporter springen.
Und wenn man selbst recht schnell genug ist und in den Teleporter springt, dann fällt man da drunter. Also man kann da nicht weiter, aber es ist cool gemacht.
Er runnt auch Opposing Force. Können wir uns auch mal angucken.
Nice, that's huge. Because of the self-ghost, that was very important.
Alter wie schnell bitte war der gerade durch das erste level durch das muss ich mir noch mal kurz angucken
Normalerweise willst du sollst du da über die plattformen aus runter hüpfen
Okay
Easy Clap
That was very important
Huge
Das erste Stand-Up
hat einfach mal 15 Sekunden gedauert oder so
Das Game kommt überhaupt nicht mehr hinterher
Das Game kackt komplett ab
Da bin ich mal gespannt, wie das jetzt läuft.
Weil ich glaube, Damage triggern muss er schon noch, weil sonst geht es ja nicht weiter eigentlich.
Okay, vielleicht kann man ja auch bis zum Schluss irgendwie durchglitchen oder durchballern quer über die Map.
Ach das Ding läuft auf festgelegten Faden, das war mir auch nie klar.
Ich dachte das ist irgendwie halbwegs dynamisch, aber anscheinend nicht.
Ja wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich kannst du den Weltrekord verbessern, oder wahrscheinlich
kann er den Weltrekord verbessern einfach indem man ihm mal ne schnellere SSD sponsort.
Das es schneller lädt.
Ich weiß nicht, zählen die Ladezeiten mit rein?
Ah der Timer bleibt stehen, ok.
Sonst, sonst hätte ich ihm ne SSD gesponsort.
Irgendeine 50 Milliarden Terabyte die Sekunde NVMe mit RGB und Kühler
Alter
What? Wait a minute
Das war gerade ein komplettes Level
Guck mal, hier ist das Gunnarsch Level fertig
und jetzt kommt das nächste jetzt kommt das nächste level so achtung fertig
das ist normalerweise das level wo man so auf diesen tentakel dinger nach
außen nach oben hopfen muss das sind das hat zwei sekunden gedauert das level
gerade ist hinter das der level titel steht sogar noch da aber das ist fertig
schon. Und jetzt kommt schon diese Fabrik. Ne, noch nicht die Fabrik, gleich die Fabrik.
Alles klar, jetzt kommt die Fabrik.
Okay, alles klar.
Das Level, das ist normalerweise das nervigste Zen-Level überhaupt, diese Fabrik.
Ich bin der letzte...
...Dämon
Wow, wow, wow, wow, wow!
Yes!
I fucking did it!
Let's fucking go!
Alter!
I kept my shit
somewhat together.
I did it!
Gleich applaudiert er!
What a drama at the end, but holy
Shit, man, wir haben es geschafft!
Minus siebeneinhalb!
Hey, ja!
Los geht's, Mann!
Oh, es ist hier, Mann!
Heftiger Run!
MonkaW!
Es ist hier, Leute!
Ja!
Übrigens,
exzellenter Musikgeschmack hat er am Start hier.
Ja!
krass also
Hut ab ich
mir fehlen die worte leute
heftig extrem heftig
Wie viel views hatten das video was so 35k
Das das sollte mehr haben
Das ist der aktuelle weltrekord xpain
xxpain underscore xx
Das ist das ist der aktuelle weltrekord
Vor einem monat wurde mario 64 zero star geknackt, okay, können wir uns anderen mal angucken
4,5 Stunden wäre jetzt für heute reich.
Ich habe Angst, die Splits anzuschauen.
Ich habe Angst, die Splits anzuschauen, weil ich weiß, dass ich so weit voraus war.
Meine erste Hälfte der Runde war absolut verrückt.
Krass.
Oh mein Gott.
Heilige Scheiße, Mann.
Oh.
Oh mein Gott.
Los geht's.
Okay, also es war ein Run auf Easy mit der Release-Version vermutlich, also mit der alten Version, nicht mit der Steam-Version, mit der alten Version, die es damals noch auf CD gab.
Scriptless, was wahrscheinlich so viel heißt wie, ich kenne mich damit nicht so gut aus, aber was wahrscheinlich so viel heißt wie ohne irgendwie Bunny-Hop-Skripts und solche Geschichten.
Ja, aber wirklich echt heftiger Run.
Meinst du, er wird bald gebrochen?
Ich kann es nicht einschätzen.
Ich meine, guck mal, er hat...
Some of Best Segments ist er nochmal eine Minute schneller.
Also ja, theoretisch, aber...
Da muss halt auch wirklich wieder alles zusammenkommen.
Keine Ahnung, dafür kenne ich mich zu schlecht mit dem Game aus, was Speedruns angeht.
um das einschätzen zu können und ich weiß auch nicht wie gut andere sind aber
das war auf jeden fall eines der krassesten runs die ich je gesehen habe
ja da kann er sich zurecht freuen
kanaga tv ja ihr könnt ja wenn ihr wenn ihr half life speedrun sehen wollt könnt
ihr aber der gelegenheit gerade mal einen follow da lassen jemand im chat meinte
Er ist öfters abends online, aber krasser Scheiß, also eines der heftigsten Runs, die ich je gesehen habe
Okay, Leute
Ich geh jetzt off
Und
Ich verspreche euch, wir spielen Half-Life fertig. Ich mache, ich mache kurz mal hier aus das Game
Also wie gesagt, ich verspreche euch, wir spielen Half-Life fertig, Black Mesa habe ich ja die Zen-Levels, glaube ich, nie im Stream fertig gespielt komplett.
Was sagst du eigentlich zum Release vom neuen Counter-Strike?
Lässt mich ein bisschen kalt? Nicht so hundertprozentig mein Game?
Einfach, weil ich zu schlecht bin?
Es nicht.
Alles klar, Leute, wir sehen uns. Bis denn, macht's gut, CU.